hello everybody
happy monday to you all this beautiful
monday morning uh march 7th
good afternoon everybody
coming at you at 206 pm
nice the weather out here now that
sunny
a little chilly out there 50 degrees
i don't know what i'm doing
guys welcome the show
we're here we're back we got lots to
talk about
hope everyone had a good weekend
gotta think uh hello fresh real fast
here at the top new season means new
seasonal recipes and now it's easier
than ever with fresh ingredients
delivered to your door hellofresh brings
the farmers market to you get 16 free
meals plus three
gifts with code h3tv16 hellofresh.com
h3tv16
shout outs to hellofresh look at these
beautiful meals
boom real fast boom bam bam bam boom
boom okay thank you
did they up their free meals again is it
16 free meals now it's like every time
they
it's just gonna keep up you don't hurt
me they're like people feed the
ukrainian army by you if you use code
h3tv
it's 14 pages
you guys have a good weekend
yeah it was good
yeah
why did you hate batman so much it was
fine like i saw the movie there's no
spoilers so don't worry i liked it
my gripe with the batman movie by the
way the first movie i've seen in theater
in like god over two years so that was
kind of nice
i was falling asleep and maybe you were
tired i've got to blame the moon i never
sleep i was really rooting for robert
patterson too
i don't know a lot of i have a whole
list actually i don't know if we want to
get to it but sure i'll debate you but
before we do guys call in 808 hot meme
the hater said the haters calling was
good so i guess we welcome haters
[Music]
haters out there let's talk
you
know or maybe not maybe they have to be
a hater but maybe have a dissenting
opinion about something
uh that we can talk about
you know um
my gripe with the batman movie was just
that it was pg-13 like i felt like they
were consistently
holding back
because this was the batman that was
supposed to be gritty you know and dark
and crazy
and batman he's a disturbed man and i
feel like they really
there was parts where he's just
pummeling people's face and there was
just no gore at all and it's like come
on
all right amy get out your list here
roger ebert let's hear what you have to
say let's start with the good the acting
was great
i like the i'm sorry
i literally i just said oh sorry i like
the kurt cobain vibes of movies
uh
i like that most of the movie was at
night and this is like the first time
we've seen the batman movie that gotham
actually is a [ __ ] like they always
talk about it in the other movies but we
don't really see it
in this movie you're like oh yeah
gotham's a straight up [ __ ]
maybe yeah maybe maybe i like the idea
of like uh
you know just like batman was fear and
you know a lot of footsteps and he
actually instilled fear in people
uh
and i like that it was like his first
two years as batman i thought those were
some cool concepts
now the bad
starting right out the gate the pacing
was [ __ ] the opening scene literally had
me scared off the jump
we're like they're looking through the
window and that that just took forever
and i thought it was looking at the
wayne family this wait wait i want to do
spoiler i'm not i'm not doing anything
this is the first
i mean do you think that you're
desensitized because you're like a huge
marvel fan and those movies are like
made for kindergartners with attention
spans of five seconds i love the dark
knight movies yeah i do too but they're
more action
actiony i mean no
okay you don't like the pacing okay what
else i mean there was a few scenes like
at one point
they were seeing a video of someone
being choked yeah and she's like
and then after like 30 seconds for a
choking the character's like oh my god
jesus christ he's choking her
that i don't remember there was some
weird dialogue
there's
there was uh his name is vengeance
like i don't think they only refer to
him as batman i think a few times but
like catwoman calling him vengeance
throughout the whole movie was so cringe
it was really
off i think she was okay how do you feel
about that vengeance what do you think i
think she was being sarcastic yeah but
he was just saying because he said
something about okay all right tough
crowd right
baby's a tough crowd
also the dude cracked every riddle in
five seconds he's a genie i know bruce
but like literally there was no he was
like
by the way they were easy batman is the
you don't understand the character he's
the greatest detective that ever
understands and that's not like a
hyperbole he is he's a genius bro
my boy's wicked smile
and well he wasn't smart enough to walk
away from a bomb to the face not
that's not spoiler you are you're just
saying too much bro okay that's the last
thing i'm gonna say but like he just
legit stood there he just stood there i
don't know
i mean it's not a spoiler because it
didn't lead to anything it was just well
it's not a spoiler but i i don't know
you you gotta you just you didn't like
the film
and that's fine i wanted to i really
wanted to how could but you fell asleep
so how can you be i didn't i was about
to fall asleep did anyone else see it
oh you saw it ian yeah yeah what'd you
think
i i thought it was okay thank you
it was fine yeah it's not the best
batman
it's not the worst
it was just that's how i felt did you
feel like the pg-13 rating kind of held
it back
maybe
i don't know i thought they did a good
job of making him seem scary without
having to show a bunch of blood and
gore and stuff but my issue was i felt
like the villain was kind of
half-baked a little yeah
uh you you know without spoiling i feel
like you don't really
get to interact with the villain very
mm-hmm and paul dano the actor he's
fantastic yeah everything i've seen him
in he's been incredible and i feel like
they kind of hid him that's true he
didn't really get to see him flourish
and and be scary he was so like tucked
away that was kind of wonderful
that's a great point i think that would
have that would have greatly enhanced
the film it more interacts between
batman and the riddler
because that's kind of like what the
batman series is all about is like the
comparison of batman interacting with
the villains
but uh the act i mean they got amazing
actors man the roster on that was was
crazy yeah the acting was great
uh what about uh do you have a nacho
review how are those nachos
nachos were good very probably the worst
um
food to eat in the dark during a movie
[Laughter]
they were good but i would not recommend
eating nachos in a movie theater oh and
then the the uh
the usher or whatever because we went to
this theater where they like serve you
and she's just clearing [ __ ] it's kind
of weird because they just come out in
the middle of the film they're like
here's your check
here you sign here and [ __ ] you know and
then the other thing is she was trying
to clear plates from
there's like a little tray and then the
table and then the chairs are together
and she's clearing plates and she
spilled a whole tub of popcorn on me and
then just walked away
oh man just walked away
so i they go i mean it's fine i just
like literally scooped hordes of popcorn
off me
that happened to me with hot coffee at
one of those things hot coffee yeah
not fun and they just walked away they
didn't walk away they were apologetic
but they still spilled it on me i mean
it was an accident right i think she was
too embarrassed and didn't want to deal
with it which is fine as a waiter i
totally understand
totally
you know
but okay
what would you give about one out of ten
i didn't hate it i just didn't think it
was
it was good i'd say your six exact quote
was that movie was [ __ ] dog [ __ ]
yeah your background my knee jerk was
yes dog [ __ ]
i mean i don't know i was really excited
for it i was hoping it'd be good so let
down mm-hmm
well anyway i thought it was like maybe
a six i mean not spectacular but pretty
good
that's what i gave it a six better or
worse than the uh how do we give it the
same writing
yeah what
what'd you say then was it better or
worse than the uh jim carrey riddler
movie
uh way better way better than that one
yeah okay fair enough
uh sam and i yesterday went to this like
um it was a screening of all of the
animated short films nominated for an
oscar
and we thought it was going to be all
these like cute little like pixar disney
shorts the first one is like super
adorable
and then
they start playing this short film that
was about like the secret police in
chile
torturing people it was an animated
movie
and there were all these kids in the
theater and god
there was one scene in particular that
was just
horrifying it was so disgusting and i'm
sitting there like going oh my god
there's so many children
it was it was it was upsetting yeah
that's great
all right now let me stick it in his eye
socket
that'll teach him
yeah yeah that one okay by the way
people in the chat are saying it was gr
a lot of people saying it was great
better than dark knight i've actually
heard people saying
it's their favorite batman movie
people are pissed at me right now yeah
well yeah i saw you this is what i see
happening amy because you you're a man
of the people you're reading the chat
and you're backpedaling from your take
oh no i'm i'm not i'm i'm talking [ __ ]
in the chat
i i said you guys are crying about a
movie i'm this is [ __ ] hilarious
no
all right it was good it was it was okay
it was a 10 actually now that i read the
chat it wasn't bad
all right let's move it on eh
oh
daniel oh yeah dan had a wendy williams
segment guys
you got this sound bited uh zach i do
okay good
yeah so we kind of someone spotted this
moment
dan
is the new wendy williams listen closely
because apparently on your soul i didn't
know what you're saying dude
[Laughter]
what
i i was when
uh you guys sent the clip this weekend
i was baffled i had to watch it though i
didn't know five or six times to even
understand what was happening
it's like you pivoted away and then yeah
i stumbled over my words go ahead zach
hit me with that
i still don't know what's going on
i think he just went he just changed
what he wanted to say and but stammering
that's good content it's epic
i'm gonna come
yep
i would uh
dj khaled we're still watching dj khaled
videos in 2022 again real quick
but you got something for me yeah you
guys saw the dispatch thing
okay no 11 minute compilation of you
mispronouncing words
no nobody's debating that but you act
like nobody talks about that okay fair
enough you just went ah
i know that's not enough we can't have
the one moment of you can have a moment
okay
you want to watch it go ahead we'll
watch the whole thing
i'm not going
i mean they're a dude
yes dj khaled he's back baby
oh he's playing basketball you know this
is going to be good
kyle's got mad skill bro
here it is oh where is he he ain't here
he ain't here
[Music]
everybody's watching
one more time
oh oh you actually got that one
give up you should have cut it do not
give up
if you fall get up
you keep going wow he turns it into a
whole inspirational thing so much ice on
me
another one
well he really turned that around right
yeah
you probably should have just cut it
after that first myth
you know what i mean yeah it's it would
have been funnier yeah just
don't matter
but but i did like like you said you
know how he kind of uh
parlayed it into a life lesson we the
best moment yeah yeah
shout out dj khaled
um oh so is amaranth is sending us a jar
fart eh yep that's exciting
so zach are you committed to smelling it
it seems like ms kipp already did it
well yeah um
i mean i don't know in this clip if he
was you know exaggerating but
so based on his reaction
i'm thinking she gotta put a little
sulfur bomb in there or something
because there ain't no way
i do i don't think
a fart could hold its stink like that
for that long
that's a big accusation
and she's a friend of the show like well
here why can't you tell me what you
think i mean
back up
miss kept acting like he doesn't want to
inhale every molecule in there
one
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i think she's snuck a little sulfur
something
we should uh do a maybe one of our
horses do an experiment we should jar
like one of zak's
that's a really good that's comparison
yeah we need to expose her lies oh
interesting maybe we could send it back
to her
can you smell ours we'll smell you we
send our regards
zach's on that keto diet too no that's
gonna be oh yeah
it's gonna be 100
yeah i think she did a little fart spray
in there it has to be
you know
i guess we'll find out
can you imagine buying a thousand dollar
squirt of fart spray because that's
what's happening
that's some [ __ ] dude i mean for her
charging that much i'm inclined to to
believe her like i feel like there's no
way i mean that's just it's just that's
fraught we need an investigation yeah
that's that's grand theft even isn't it
i don't know if it's grand theft it's
fraud it's at least false advertising
[Music]
amaranth [ __ ] in her butt
it says
go ahead let's play that again like we
gotta figure out how to dig ourselves
out of this fraud
we gotta think of how to dig our way out
of this that's what our poop says
so right you're right that it's not
exactly grand theft but the the
threshold for grand theft is 950 dollars
so she's charging a thousand so i mean
it's it's it's it's getting into serious
crime territory if she is it's
about it yeah she's not stealing
by the way zach i watched that
documentary recommended man that thing
was depressing bro i had to bail halfway
through which one of the criminals that
they follow for like 30 years oh yeah i
mean i gave you a fair warning you did
it it was good it was really good but
yeah
it was depressing it's not yeah i mean
yes
because it's like follows the family and
it's the kids that are just
what they're all getting arrested and
going to jail no they're just horrible i
mean they're horrible they're doing
drugs in front of their kids they're
leaving their kids by themselves all day
the kid you there's shots of the kids
being like why don't you love me if
you're going out then you don't love
it's just no it was gnarly definitely no
it's so sad i mean i just feel so bad
for those kids man yeah but um
yeah i gave you a fair warning
that it was
gnarly booked up
uh here comes the ayden ross meme this
one was pretty good now i'm not the
wisest i'm not the smartest guy in the
room but i mean i'm smarter than this
right making nato's border with russia
the longest it's ever been wow
this is getting interesting i actually
understand it bro soviet countries left
between russia and nato but ukraine and
georgia both wanted to join nato for
georgia
and that
i gotta be [ __ ] tripping
is this is this maybe years ago how is
atlanta all over here
you can't be for real atlanta is all the
way over here
uh
uh we were talking about this the other
day and love love thinks that he's he's
faking it i don't know man but he is
dumb
no i don't think it's he necessarily is
faking it but i do think it's possible
why would he want to be
it's kind of perceived as being that
dumb i think it's just kind of like a
schtick maybe of
i mean maybe he is just that dumb i
think he is man it's definitely a thing
on twitch though that people are playing
kind of dumb to entertain
um and then they the longer they play
dumb the dumber they become if that
makes sense right
i think maybe he made the mistake and
then he just played into it i think he
really thought atlanta was uh
was in central asia yeah yeah
georgia
georgia
a dream of succobliete
no oh god i swear to god no no no no no
no no no listen no no no do not [ __ ]
think oh he's trolling i swear to god
i'm not controlling
how
come on a second pull the map that
crypto [ __ ]
i swear my life i'm not showing on on
everything i love about trolling bro
okay is there just a website
he's picking his nose while talking
about joy atlanta pictures it was a lot
bro what is he
you can't do that on stream i try to
think but nothing happens
trying to think but nothing happens i've
seen multiple clips of him where that
isn't even the focus and i've noticed
he's always digging in there i don't
know
it's a little weird
now that is weird that's what i'm saying
bro
i think he's struggling to be honest
with you guys yeah probably i think his
brain is a working overdrive
fantastic
so much to catch up on it
um
okay so here let's get into some some
meat and bones here so they say so jeff
whitak
as you guys know
his buddy
did a drive-by on our house
they got the message
and with the caption of uh
hey i don't remember exactly what it was
but it was like hey you i know where you
live
i can get to you okay
does anyone have the direct quote
but anyway he drove by my house in the
morning and at night and then we
realized the first drive through
was even before i mentioned him
and um
that's really disturbing and i don't
know what i ever did to jeff
i feel like i goofed on them a bit
but i was team jeff i wanted to help him
i was gonna help him with lawyers i was
you know we were gonna have him on the
show
i just i don't know why he hates me so
much
in this clip
where he had tana and mike on
tana literally says that he
told her he wants to kill me
is this funny
i'm missing the joke here
um
he said ethan klein don't worry i have
all the intel i need
yeah
very menacing threatening
and then when he got back to miami or
wherever he lives he goes hey they got
the message in hollywood
i'm gonna leave his friend out of it
because that guy is just i don't know
man not right
and also are you guys going into this
whole murder [ __ ] because i can't be a
part of people no we're just chilling
you know if you're murdering i can't do
it i'm a [ __ ] fellow
[Music]
we're just joking around
right i'm down we're just joking around
we drove by his house twice through a
gated community
it took pictures of his license plate
and inside his house
don't you get the joke it's funny it's a
joke
i killed his dog
real funny huh
i went in his backyard and watched him
through his kitchen window what's not
funny about that it's a joke
for context
you want like h3 done
you told me you want h3 dead
she said that right
[Music]
i didn't mishear that
that's what you said
why why does he want me dead
like
i don't understand what i did to offend
these guys so much
i did an italian voice is that all it
takes jeff to make you want to kill
someone i mean
i don't get it man
it's just not
i don't know bro i don't know
oh no so one of my friends went over
there and like
filmed the house and then ethan got all
scared and texted me a bunch of stuff
and he got all scared his friend
people was
it's hey it's not my fault ethan got
scared he's there with his family and
his newborn baby and his two-year-old
he got scared what's the big deal it's
his problem
my friend lied to get into the gated
community twice on two separate
occasions the fake id
with the fake id yep yeah
it's a totally normal thing for a grown
man to have it was just a little joke he
got scared it's not my problem
hey if he got scared that's his problem
if you didn't get the joke
what kind of funny man is he he's
supposed to be a comedian that's what i
do
ha ha joker man
what do i make you laugh what am i some
kind of a clown
like how did you just
oh
god
you come to my house dude this is
godfather you're doing more of like a
good fellas
but that's what i'm saying is like we
need like a slightly different
vibed italian mafia music
for this new
right wise guy character yeah i need a
wise guy yeah you need wisely all right
i'll look into it
yeah so what i put a whack on him it's
not that serious it's just a joke he
said kill his dogs
take a [ __ ] on his doorstep it's all
funny
you don't get it
you're the comedian you're supposed to
get jokes
i sent my goon over to your house
who's six two and three hundred pounds
ha ha
funny
he got scared not my problem
[Music]
i told my friend i wanted to kill him
what's the big deal
i told tana i want him dead
it's just a joke
basically said instead of putting out a
hit on him that you had one of your
friends go there
he chose
yo yo yo so is tana giving away the
the behind the scenes here a little bit
sounds like it she said i mean i don't
think jeff was
serious in the sense that he would
actually do that but it sounds like he
was super pissed and behind the scenes
was like ranting about no tana said here
and correct me if i'm under
misunderstanding she said said instead
of putting out a hit on him that you had
one of your friends go there she said
instead of putting a hit on
[Music]
hey
him
put a hit on people that make fun of me
what's the big deal you know
i'm a nice guy until you make fun of me
then i'll kill you
she said instead of putting a hit on him
i'm going to send my friend to scare him
she said he told her that
right it sure sounds like that's what
she said and
yet we talked about we talked about the
whole timeline of all this yeah we did
last time but like yeah so
the first time we were goofing on jeff a
bit
before his friend was even involved and
then we found out from the security that
he's friend came to our house
the day before we ever even talked about
his friend right correct because jeff
was like it was just my friend he took
he he has a mind of his own i can't
control but he actually came
but tan is saying jeff sent him to my
house to scare him
just to scare him a little bit otherwise
i'd have to kill him
i mean it makes more sense than him just
arbitrarily stalking your house before
ever saying anything about him right
right yes it
would are you guys hanging out with a
dude that's talking about killing people
for making fun of him
j also i i gotta say
um
mike seems very concerned and i like
that for him i mean i like that he's
like yeah this i actually look at his
face right now he's like yo guys um
can we stop talking i can't do this
right now i don't want to be involved i
[ __ ] my pants today i gotta say mike's
slowly growing on me
okay don't say that around zach
interesting sorry zach
look everyone you know if he has a
redemption arc he has a redemption arc
the guy can still [ __ ] his gym shorts
though once you [ __ ] your gym shorts the
gym shorts are always dirty you
understand yeah he can be a good guy but
have dirty gym shorts
he's a vengeance
all right let's and then also i got to
give a shout out to tana really for just
laying it out there too
she's like listen you threatened to kill
the guy for making fun of you just say
it like it is
happening there he chose to do it he got
made fun of and it was his own decision
to go into he got away
not what happened still lying about that
he did not do that because he was made
fun of he was at the house before we
ever talked about him so stop saying
that dude
just lying again just like he did when
he came on our show the dude can't
[ __ ] help himself he just [ __ ]
when he's out when he's talking he's
lying
all right damn relax he's gonna kill me
if you lay it on too hard
dan if you lay it on too hard he's gonna
whack me
i'm gonna tell a funny joke on him the
cops will know who did it at least
yeah if i just wind up dead remember
remember remember who did it
listen
i'm a i'mma tell you a joke funny man
how about i come into your house and
kill your whole family does that sound
funny to you
get it it's a joke
that's a cute dog what if you wake up
with his head in your bed
chose to do it he got made fun of and it
was his own decision to go and do it
yeah he's ignoring the fact he came
before we ever talked about him yep
also it's so weird whenever i talk to
jeff about it he's like listen
he's his own man i can't tell him what
to do
it's like
what
and i you know i stopped him after ethan
had asked i told him back off
why don't you call
why don't you call ethan into the show
right
that was a sound bite i don't think he
wants to come anywhere around me anymore
i need a disclaimer i don't want any
part of this
understandable like murder [ __ ] because
i can't be a part of it either
it's not going to be good for jeff it
never is
i'll tell you jeff
you're not you're not going to look good
because you're [ __ ] lying he came
before i ever talked about him and i
have proof okay
okay ethan oh god he's such a menace bro
why i literally like i goofed on him a
bit
okay
i'm i wanted to support jeff that's the
thing i was even taught i was like i'm
gonna help you i'm gonna get you a
lawyer i wanted to come on the show you
wanted to be his best friend i was i
kept saying yeah i wanted to be his best
friend we were gonna i was gonna help
him i just i don't know like i'm what's
team jeff why
the
hostility
not even like hostile in the sense of
uh
like a keemstar sense it's more like an
actual threat of violence hostility
which is something i've not dealt with
from another creator
that doesn't seem normal
he's welcome to talk call in though man
you know
here's a funny joke how about i burn
down your house
ha ha get it
hey
knock knock
[Music]
who's there put up your hands i'm gonna
[ __ ] kill you
get it
the joke
what don't you get funny man that was
[Laughter]
funny here's another one
here's another one
oh the music like restarted me
knock knock who guess who's there
a six to italian man with nothing to
lose is gonna strangle you to death
get it
that's a nice baby you got shame if
something happened to him
[Laughter]
i'm sorry but like this is actually dis
bro i didn't know what to say about this
but
so disturbing
it really is and you know of all the
petty beefs we've been in in my life on
youtube which is many many many many i
mean and and i've gone in way harder on
people let's be let's be honest
barely went in on jeff just goofed on
him a bit but i was supportive of him on
the whole
never threats of violence man
or
even ryan cavanaugh hasn't shown up at
your house no
maybe ryan paid them off we've dedicated
like a thousand hours to talking about
that guy yeah ryan has handled it more
maturely than they have and he sued me
four times right
i don't sue people
i just kill him get it
sometimes it's easier just to make the
problem go away
i wonder what he's doing to david to be
honest if i was david i'd be scared for
my safety because if that's what they're
doing to me i think they've
i think well that's david might be
taking a dirt nap the same guy that
stalked your house is like posting on
instagram
repeatedly about how he wants to find
david and offering bounties for his
location and stuff yeah which kind of
takes on like he's just joking around
too except it takes a little bit of a
different context when you know what
yeah there he was he posted a video
where he had like a
the dude had in his trunk
a crate of yeezys like it literally
quote unquote fell off the back of a
truck
and he says i got a pair of yeezys for
anyone that could tell me where the bald
eagle is
[Music]
right the bald eagle i was trying to
remember what he keeps calling i'm
trying to skin a bald eagle right
dude just sue him why do you gotta
threaten to kill people
just sue him
like it's not rocket science bro
and just leave me the [ __ ] alone bro
i don't know
so that's it i mean i don't know what
else to say about it that video was
pretty funny of the guy with the yeezys
trunk but i'm not even gonna [ __ ] i'm
not even gonna show his friend man yeah
he is like his friend is like the goon
though he's like the he's the muscle
he's the muscle you don't want to get a
visit from my buddy
i'll tell you what
we'll bury you in a pair of yeezys send
you off real nice
also jason revealed oh man
i don't know jeff can't be happy about
this either
because jason actually just
jeff was saying that
um
geek sponsored this jeff was saying that
date on twitter can you pull up the
exact tweets because i don't want to
miss i don't want to mischaracterize
what he said
but he was basically saying that he
there was this roast of bryce hall that
just aired
that seat geek put on
and jeff said that his whole set was cut
from the
from the roast
now let's read it specifically so we
don't miss quote
he said i'm no longer part of the
roaster bryce hall my entire set will be
cut due to censorship and david dobrik
being involved i refuse to be a part of
anything that scumbag is involved down
free here on out well that's fair
he basically says
some of his jokes were censored
and he doesn't want to be a part of
anything with david so
that seems accurate
what he said more about it no
uh
i chose to have my set cut they tried to
remove half my jokes was supposed to be
a comedy show i didn't say anything i
wouldn't say in my own youtube videos
this is all because that coward was
there and he can't take jokes
so
okay
i think there's more
hey look he's sponsored again congrats
you bald eagle he needs help with
insults the bald eagle thing is not that
good yeah it's not
not very strong i can help you write
jokes jeff if we were buddies but
i'm gonna call david i'm gonna call
david bald every chance i get but if you
mention my eye i'll [ __ ] kill you
so okay so here's what jason had to say
about it which is really like
the vlog squad guys never comment
publicly on this [ __ ] ever so this is
pretty spectacular they're a great
company they're a great app and more
importantly they're they're just great
people to work with they uh
they really get it they really made the
roast so fun they came and gave away
tickets there was all kinds of stuff
that they did that night that was really
cool um and basically there were a bunch
of jokes that they wanted cut out of it
and i said of course you know let's see
you guys are paying and that's the way
it works with brands brands
you know they're paying you so you know
they want uh certain things gone and the
things that they asked to cut i didn't
think were that crazy um
um the jokes that jeff got hey david i
hope you [ __ ] die and guess what if
it's me that did it well then my dreams
came true
seeking like maybe a little coming on
tone it down a little bit a couple
minutes come on it's free speech
hey david
the next time you go out
i'll be in your house waiting
ha ha get it
see cake's like
maybe not threaten him like
more more jokey
oh let me try again
hey david
next time you start your car
will be your last
it's a car bomb
they're like that what's the joke it's
just a threat of mine
hey come on this is censorship
hey david i'm gonna make you pay
with your life
i'm gonna kill your parents
your siblings your pets
everything you love
look at me
you're dead the bottom line is you
cannot be trusted see kiki's like that's
not a joke you're just literally
threatening a man
come on it's a joke you believe in free
speech come on
you think i'm really gonna hurt him
so jeff had four or five jokes that were
cut
and so what's been going on why the
roast isn't out yet is because i've been
um
you know going back and forth with jeff
and seki trying to find a compromise
um
yes in terms of what jokes are people so
[ __ ] busy they can't they have to
film videos in their car i i don't get
this video this is a common format it's
like dude are you so busy
you can't just film this
not driving i mean maybe
i don't think so it's a one minute video
hey i'm so busy
this is the only second of free time go
ahead ab you want to say something i
mean i understand for audio purposes but
i don't get while driving if the car is
still i think it's okay it's fine yeah
but if you're driving i don't understand
that i've always felt that was weird as
well
would you jerry seinfeld yeah
no
just take the video
you're not that [ __ ] busy jason ash i
know you're not stop laughing it's not
funny
jason nasa addiction that's about to
come to my house and kill me now that i
made fun of him
that's the new norm
yeah
i gotta beef up security i made some
jokes about bailey eilish
that that's a world huh where people
just come and kill you when you make
jokes about them
and so geek sponsored this roast they're
great
so i mean
it's not i think if you go back and read
the tweets i don't think it's
necessarily contradictory
because
jeff said some of my jokes were cut
wait there's more [ __ ] i don't watch the
whole thing
stand by
dead air i don't think the sponsor here
go ahead yeah i got jeff to cut two of
the jokes then there were three more
that jeff uh wouldn't budge on and he
said i want to pull my set and so that's
basically it that's there's no drama to
it um there's it's unfortunate because
that was so good and so funny
that's what he wants to do and you know
i uh i got jeff to cook so there you
have it
he said jeff said i cut it because they
were censoring my jokes which was true
and then he said because i don't want to
be you know part of anything with david
which you know he did pull it out so he
was telling the truth fair enough yeah
also
jason would lie to protect if david was
like i don't want those jokes in there
because it makes me look bad i feel like
jason would lie to protect him
and be like seeking i guess that that's
i guess that's the thing is like
rereading jeff's tweets
with this context it it does seem
like straightforward that
what he was doing but
i think we all interpreted it
as
david was insisting that these jokes be
cut definitely which doesn't sound like
is what happened it sounds like seeky
according to jason it could be that
david didn't because
another thing jeff said is that david
came over and had editorial rights on
the documentary they filmed together to
make david look less bad so right i
believe that david would do that yeah it
could be
now did you see my
little side note in there
right under side note uh jason nash
hairline can
cam pointed out let's check it out
that's pretty exciting how old is jason
at he's like almost 50.
yeah that's pretty impressive geek
sponsored just for yeah he he he has a
really good hairline 50 year old man i
mean yeah his hair is beautiful too
actually yeah hold on let me get a
close-up jason nash
let's just get a real close up here of
the hairline oh look at my hair
he's got like beautiful straight hair
damn bro that hairline is insane right
now we got to get him to pull it back
though you know let's see if we can
that's a pretty clean shot of the
hairline yeah
that is impressive
i mean compared to david's who's like
half his age you know who
you know who reminds me of his uh uh
what's that filmmaker uh
he makes the really weird films
twin peaks oh david lynch he has an ins
yeah his hair is insane yeah he might be
the king yeah he really might be in the
game what's his age she's probably
pushing 70 yeah easily and i think jason
his hair is gorgeous dude yeah david
lynch is the man and it's all gray and
it hasn't moved an inch 76 76 in this
man
has still the hair a hairline like this
how is that possible
how's that possible i don't know
him and uh wasn't it lucas too that we
realized yeah has like
it's like almost down to his eyebrows
it's like crazy
oh my god oh lord god look at that head
oh jesus
jesus lord i can't believe this i can't
believe what i'm saying
yeah that that man might actually be the
airline you might be the king wait like
this is the king in every regard look at
this [ __ ] i love this man
what an inch
what's the one thing you do
the friday thing dan what he announces
well he does so
for like a decade now david lynch has
done a daily weather report that he puts
up oh really yes
isn't that frankie mcdowell's territory
he might be ukraine
i don't know who that is this is frankie
mcdowell we got dangerous weather
tornado warning for nebraska everybody
oh no frankie mcdonald
internet legend i do know who you're
talking about
um
yeah here it is seven hours ago
good morning
it's march seven
two three get ready
and it's a monday thank you mcdonald
here in l.a
uh beautiful sunny morning
he's done this one years like a decade i
can't get my three years i don't know
look at that he wears like the same
outfit every day too right then
he's just always wearing the glasses
well let's hear
43 degrees fahrenheit
around 6 celsius
today i was thinking about the song
always gives a song suggestion as well
by the beatles
from the year 1969
this afternoon it'll be going up to
72 degrees fahrenheit
didn't expand on the song
i've been thinking about this song today
and it looks like we're going to be
enjoying
those
beautiful blue skies and golden sunshine
all along the way
everyone
have a great day
all right everybody i'll pull up frankie
mcdowell and let's see who does it
better okay
i know david lynch is the man but uh he
is a legend living legend but he ain't
no weather man
i'm telling you frankie oh lord
macdonald
mcdowell mcdowell mcdonald mcdonald
uh
okay we got uh four days ago
big boy
boxing
gloves
okay okay uh david's was a little bit
more
you i don't know what that was but this
is gotta find the weather okay yeah find
the weather oh me saying no don't no no
no massive storm to hit massachusetts
yeah click that
this is frankie mcdonald to my own team
station live from city nova scotia
massive snowstorm is headed towards
massachusetts on
friday february 25th 2010
it's going to bring up to
six to 12 inches or more especially in
boston massachusetts springfield and
massachusetts 10 pound massachusetts
provincetown this is useful information
a lot of stuff they'll be building
useful information but especially in
cape cod you know this is this is like
an emergency weather report we have uh
does he generally just do the emergency
yeah he's into the emergency so you can
go to david for your daily
meteorological uh information and then
when there's breaking news about a big
you know potential disastrous storm
frankie's got you covered
i think they complement each other you
know like the the world is wide enough
for both right yeah i agree
yeah i love frankie if you guys need
some extreme weather reports there's
that's the man to do it for you
absolutely
okay well jeff please just leave me the
[ __ ] alone dude and i'll leave you alone
which apparently
is
let's just make a let's just do an
armistice a
ceasefire yes yeah
i don't want any trouble dude please
fair
enough we should do our uh ads we're
good all right 50 minutes into this
[ __ ] show 50 50.
you got to keep me honest how did that
happen i just this jeff discussion got
away from us guys thank you to curology
i love curology it's so nice because i
care about my skin
but i'm not gonna i just don't want to
put in the effort to talking to a
dermatologist
to doing like mountains of research to
figure out which error which stuff to
use
what curology does is you take a
survey
you send a picture of your skin
and the dermatology provider
will
send you a perfect dermatology formula
to treat whatever's going on with your
skin
um
they were talking about
they've got all the stuff here they
they treat like the dark the dark spots
the blackheads the acne i mean
everything that you would want they're
gonna personalize this formula
to treat your skin and the other thing
that they include is
the face wash and the moisturizer and
the face wash is perfect it's so soft it
doesn't feel like it's stripping my skin
of oil same with the moisturizer it's so
soft my face doesn't feel greasy
afterwards it's a perfect uh routine
and it just
cuts out all the drama of of you know
seeing a dermatologist to get treated
so
i love it
i've been using it religiously since we
started working because i had never
heard of it but uh yeah i've been using
for about a gosh i don't know a year
maybe
um
it's a game-changing custom skincare
made up for you by a dermatology
provider to create a custom prescription
cream for your specific goals acne
clogged pores skin texture dark spots
fine lines or something else
take an online quiz upload photos of
your face and if it's a good fit they'll
ship you your formula right to your door
and it even has your name on it so you
know it's the real deal i love it i'm
sure you guys will love it too
get a 30 day free trial
at curology.com
h3 just pay five bucks for shipping and
handling that's c u r o l o g y
dot com slash h3 just get start your
free 30-day trial cancel anytime
prescription subject
to consultation thank you to curology we
love you mwah
we love you
and finally thank you to mit mobile
if you're saving more and spending less
is one of your top goals for 2022
why are you still paying insane amounts
of money every month for wireless
switching to mobile is the easiest way
to save money this year as the first
company to sell premium wireless
services online only mint mobile lets
you maximize your savings with plans
starting at just 15 bucks a month
dan is our mint mobile man
that's right
mim mobile
same as the big guys
much cheaper
saves you get the exact same service
uses the same network
i'm just trying to remember all these
well you use it you use it yes it works
just as good just as good and it's just
less money it's literally just free
money it's a no-brainer yeah
for people looking to save extra money
this year mipmobile's offers premium
wireless for just 15 bucks a month by
going online only and eliminating the
traditional cost of retail mint mobile
passes significant savings on to you all
plans come with unlimited talk and text
plus high-speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network use your own
phone with any mint mobile plan and keep
your same phone number along with all
existing contacts and with mint mobile
choose the amount of monthly data that's
right for you and stop paying for data
you never use that's right switch to my
mobile and get premium wireless service
starting at just 15 bucks a month to get
your new wireless plan for just 15 bucks
a month and to get the plan shipped to
your door for free go to mintmobile.com
h3tv
that's mintmobile.com
h3tv cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks
a month at mintmobile.com
h3tv a thank you
thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you we just
got a 50
donation from mercedes asking ab
specifically
if he has any anime recommendations
are you asking him i'm the weibo and
there's only one that a b ever recommend
you already know attack on titan all day
i'm back i'm behind two episodes damn
i'll watch him i'm behind this whole
season this like latest
it's good run it's a good yeah it's good
just waiting i don't even watch the
[ __ ] show but this guy right here got
the [ __ ] theme song stuck in my head
it's so catchy
how does it go again it's the death
metal one right yeah yeah rumbling
it's a yeah yeah it's a good one
was that funny dan you didn't like my
rendition
so i'm looking for a call right now
let's see
got cursed up by shoe nice
oh interesting
um
what about joey
[Music]
joey
what do you mean by that
the caller joey
um
joey
i'm looking baby you can relate to ethan
about having small hands like him wanted
to connect over people saying they have
smile what is this a support group i
don't need to talk to joey i have
massive hands
let me take a call from all the bald
people that you could have a supporter
yeah we could do that
we could definitely do that
all right sorry joe you're getting
dropped
rip
keep on trucking those small hands wait
wait wait i gotta hear this
okay michael
michael ethan all right tell me what
happened
all right
so yeah i was at the oliver tree concert
last night
yeah and
he brought logan paul on to saying
life goes on like you did
did that really happen i couldn't
believe it
yeah
he was in cleveland last night and they
were on the show i do know that
i gotta say
oliver's banned he's banned from the
podcast there will now be enemy of the
show
were people booing in the audience tell
me what was going on
for sure yeah
um
so like the reaction was honestly like
mixed because like you know little kids
like oliver you know no problem with
that
um
wait it was like half and half like
booing you know people from cleveland
don't really like uh paul
well um it's kind of funny if he got
booed but wait it's on a story here hold
on i gotta see this
it's on logan's ig story oh ela's
listening
yo i gotta see that can someone how do i
watch that i guess i'm logged in yeah
you're logged in yeah should be able to
pull it up ela's got the intel here let
me pull this [ __ ] up
all right logan paul
okay
you know what he else he was doing they
were doing the instagram stories back
and forth like we were doing
[Applause]
okay that i don't care about so this is
what i'm saying [ __ ] paul i'm out he
did this whole stick
oh he dressed up
but do people like logan paul like the
people the people that like oliver tree
like logan paul that seems like a weird
crossover i mean this is his home state
though so that may be a big factor right
but don't wouldn't people from ohio like
logan paul less no
well our caller seems to think so yeah
that yeah it's like who wants to own
that yeah and there was there's a good
bit of people booing and um
at one point he started a [ __ ] logan
paul chain
okay well that's funny
uh
what a nightmare
why is this happening to me
i thought we were friends
oh yeah it was
like fully like the type of the concert
was weird like once he did that
um
and then at the end of the concert
um
he brought logan and mike back on stage
and was like i took a lot of like ball
hair for looking to do that come on and
like sing in front of you guys like a
round of applause and like yeah the
reaction was mixed it was like you know
people were booing oh he was actually
trying to be like yo don't be mean to
logan because people were really turning
on him
yeah that's kind of it
yeah i like that
[Applause]
logan's turning it into the logan paul
show eh
i mean i'm sure they planned it all out
no i know but like how long was logan on
stage
he's doing like half the song and i'm
like oh no
he was on stage a lot
he said half the season yeah he came
back on like oh oh okay we think like
half the song and then he came back on
because
it was like later in the show um
and um
yeah i don't know it was weird i can't
he can't do the same stick with logan
paul
can't do that you can't have this
[ __ ] fake beef with every person
you gotta call him out yeah bro
yeah no i'm not for real
this time
well michael is calling michael did you
ask for a refund or i mean what happened
at the end of the show
um
i didn't no i didn't uh maybe maybe
maybe you can still get a refund i don't
know maybe he's still on the table
the next day yeah
how was the concert how was oliver
it was good he was you know he was
energetic and entertaining and
um
yeah it was good that was cool kind of
helpful changes and stuff well that's
fun nice at least he had a good time are
you at work right now great yeah you're
whispering are you are you trying to
work like hiding in your cubicle right
now
no no no no
it just seemed like you were really
trying to keep your voice down so
your co-workers went well you know i'm
happy
it's good it's good exposure for oliver
i'm happy he did uh got on the it seems
like his he was a hit on impulsive too
don't lie
what it was he was it was a hit you're
happy about it well i'm happy for him
it's good exposure you know
[Music]
what he's doing right yeah impulsive
oliver tree let's see the views
yeah i mean
yeah take a good 1.3 million
i need to drop something too
oliver tree took back
the love both girlfriend
oh yeah they brought a tablet for the
lovebot girlfriend and he took it back
that you're saying that now love i just
wanted it's good that you're saying that
yeah exposed
anyone else got any dirt on oliver
before we move on
i do actually yeah
good
no maybe i shouldn't say it on the show
you better say it right now now's the
time
we're taking him out no
should i how bad could it be well
type in a discord and i'll tell you if
you say it or not
yeah dan's got some real juice
apparently
let's see dance typing
oh
i don't think that's what happened
i don't think that's what happened okay
well then i won't say anything
no don't say that
don't say that yeah
i think oliver was a real treat
yeah yeah no he was it was really fun
having him on the show i keep the guitar
he gave me right uh right here always oh
yeah you need your gift you need to
break that i need you to break that in
half for me right now on camera
friendship over
i lost two best friends today jeff and
oliver man you're having a rough one i'm
sorry dude
who's gonna be my best friend now
michael will you step in
oh for sure um there are people oh
michael i was like yeah
all the time yeah all right me and
michael are best friends now thanks mike
you lose two you gain one
not a good day but it could have been
worse right mike
yeah yeah thanks for calling all right
take care appreciate that yeah thanks
all right all right bye bye
i um know devastating it is devastating
it is
here let's see
i'm looking for haters
um
chased by craze naked man lyft driver
[Music]
fitness goals
shoe nice i'm kind of interested in the
shoe nice
i mean
i don't know it's like shoe nice is
always up to shenanigans yeah is this in
person or on his live stream because he
always i bet he's got it there's no way
it's in person right he always does that
to people on his live streams
that's like his main content because i
don't wake my ass bro
no haters out there eh
no only fans you're just so loved
it's hard to be loved by you beloved by
all
all right well then i'm going to clear
the queue and um if you want to talk
some [ __ ] to ethan call in
that's what we're looking for here
wait how does either know he was oh
that's not ela
it's cam i thought eva was talking to me
oh he's using hilah's computer
he's like there was someone on who
wanted to talk about being a
conservative i was like how would even
know that
she's screening calls oh
what did your spare time yeah
all right this next story is pretty
great about the ace family
their house drama continues to unfold
man
and um
it's still good
you know their how their big mansion was
foreclosed on
and some i guess agent
one of these youtubers did a walkthrough
of their house
and the house was like gutted they like
gutted the appliances and sold them
scammed
which is apparently what degenerates do
to try to i this is degeneracy
holy crap
by its cover welcome to the ultimate
learning lesson this is a 13 million bro
i can't
i can't play you that music
he says typically owners cannot afford
payment
all appliances have been ripped out
to try and pay off the bank
the home is in total disarray
it's awesome
i mean we kind of knew that i didn't
expect them to start ripping out
appliances i mean we knew it was in
disarray but that's just corny bro to
like rip out the
dishwasher
who's gonna buy a used dishwasher that
was ripped out pawn shop i don't know
a pawn shop you think they got space for
dishwashers i don't know they're not big
i'm blood boiling
damn that's like
why didn't he just chip out the stone in
the wall
sell that to estonia or something
i mean holy crap
the heat story is still just so
unbelievable to me
yeah it really is
that they're still like and still in
denial about all of it
to this day idiot
yeah i really want to know what what
actually i mean i think we know what
happened is just that
they scammed the bank right they scammed
uh
they couldn't afford it they're being
sued like a hundred times the only
people in the world being sued more than
me at once
and by different people too true yeah
this clip was pretty good speaking of
deaf noodles uh instagram page here this
was from the bryce hall rose and it's
david laughing his ass off at excavator
jokes about jeff members of the vlog
squad here on stage
tonight we got jonah who can't see his
own penis
jason who can't see his own kids and
jeff who can't see anything
i want to get serious here for a second
and say jeff after the whole excavator
incident we all agreed no more heavy
machinery until tonight when we had to
use a forklift to get joan on stage
he's joking about
left david
the legion of doom like all of the
enemies of the show like little by
little i think i think their hatred of
us is is driving them all together you
see i am batman i think so i want to get
serious here for a second this the joker
the riddler two-face they're all teaming
up
just like in the just like in the comics
i'm gonna say jeff after the whole
excavator incident we all agreed no more
heavy machinery until tonight when we
had to use a forklift to get joan on
stage
where's fate oh why faceblinks dude get
off just [ __ ] damn why you got to be
everywhere
have some kids or something
you know what i mean anything he's
friends with bryce hall i would assume
like the part of the same circle of
hollywood people
what the [ __ ] are you saying
h3h3 humor
so we've got um
tiny tick tock
we've got a 400 year old woman i've seen
that
yeah you you sent that the other day in
the chat which you really should have
put a [ __ ] warning why it's crazy
well yeah because you just sent the link
without
any other context and i clicked it and
was just like starting
it's just like it's very disturbing it's
a little disturbing is this the one wait
where's the one the thing is i it popped
up for me again and then i looked at the
account that posted it and the account
is so weird it's like all
these click bait super elderly people
but they all are like captioned like
this woman is
400 years old i'm looking at this is all
the same lady this is the same there is
some different people in there mixed in
as well okay so um
here is what they say is a 400 year
woman that's that is a [ __ ] that is
not
oh
[ __ ] i mean she's not there's 45 million
views and all the comments are
like
believing it no she's not 400 yeah
she might be like 120 or something you
know
but holy god i mean she looks like she's
been
mummified
look how beautiful she is
wow yeah she is beautiful she's a queen
shelvin
inappropriate i mean tell lee
399 years women
here's woman
let me read some comments here
she know what the dog is doing
knows the coca-cola recipe
do we got there's got to be a way to
i guess no oh briar cares so they're
making content from like a
i think this is a re-upload i think all
these are re-uploads yeah i'm sure
although they're getting so i remember
seeing the original electronics look
there's another one she's 210 years old
and it's like some other extremely i
love that this account specialized in
super old people content but then also
just like [ __ ] post memes
yeah but kind of like peppered in there
every once in a while
she is 210.
the original account was tai i think
they had like a bunch of pie
golly dude this is so weird
this is good content they go
yo she looks oh she has like a skin
condition
i was gonna say she looks like a
overripe banana but that's insensitive
that is definitely an insensitive
what is she going to do she doesn't
[ __ ] she can't she's going to cancel
it she doesn't even know she's of where
she is
she is 210 years old no she's not like
i guess she's old don't give up oh yeah
for sure nobody's lived that long but
they just captioned like that to just
bait
stupid people the oldest person in the
world is 119 yeah exactly
damn
this woman's seen it all
interesting
i know you're looking for haters
wait
mary oh yeah bring call let them in
where's that i want to talk to them what
do you see cameron just said he has an
interesting call
okay let's talk to uh owen
so owen here
[Music]
okay
so so you were friends with mary
she's the girl mary cosby's son marries
the girl with the church where she has
the church right
yes yep um
i was best friends with her son uh
robert give a little more content you're
talking about the real housewives real
housewives of salt lake city which means
us a stunning endorsement of right now
one of the exceptionally crazy womans on
that show is a woman named
mary she has a her own church and one of
the controversies is that she people are
saying it's a cult that she is basically
saying that she is god
and one of the guys
allegedly
uh
got a reverse mortgage on his house to
donate 300 000 to the church and like
lost everything so it's kind of a
scientology situation like that
yeah okay um and and she has it and kind
of confirmed that it was kind of it's
very cold um
very much that's not an understatement
it definitely looks like that in the
show so this is owen who was apparently
friends with her son now why are you
calling in are you still friends with
him
i am not no there was a massive fallout
which led to a lot of
fighting and um
no communication after the fighting
so how do you how do you
how do you as a 18 year old
young man have a such a big falling out
with a friend
um
it was more it more had to do with my
parents
so um
there was a lot of weird so um utah it's
pretty racist um there a lot of the
areas are very racist and um
mary would sort of um she kind of had
this sort of
like racism kind of ingrained into her i
would say and she would kind of pull out
the racism card in certain scenarios and
then other ones should kind of preserve
it
um and she would
do she would call people racist when she
like disliked what people were saying um
and she would do that to like my parents
or to even me um so i was playing uh
video games with um robert in there
in the basement of the house and i beat
him um and then he flammed uh my face
wii controller and then i got called
racist for saying that he did that so
yeah so he slammed so so her son slammed
your face for beating him
yeah
and then they called well at that stan
because she does that in the show
she she would call people racist and
then actually say she got busted for
saying super racist stuff about asians
in the show so that's good oh yeah is
she she's a white very popular person oh
she's black okay she's one of these
people that says black people can't be
racist it's impossible for a black
person to be racist god oh god i got it
mary real housewives of salt lake city
well do you have anything this isn't the
one that married her grandfather this is
the one that married her grandfather oh
it is yeah yeah yeah lovely so
correction there it wasn't her
grandfather it was a step grandfather
okay yeah yeah not her biological
grandfather sure
yeah but it's her step grandfather that
makes it okay
and so is it well is it you have any
gossip you want to share with us well
you're on the phone here what give me
some dirt
not particularly
no are you a mormon um i not and no no
no no no no no okay um nope
yeah but i'm i'm not i'm not comfortable
sharing
information without knowing a lot more
um my parents know significantly more
than i do so i would love to call on the
show another time when uh my parents are
available sure let's get your parents on
the phone let's talk yeah mom and dad
for sure so is her is her son a little
[ __ ]
um
well it's not he
hits his friend when he loses a video
game so well he's probably angry because
his mom is such a weirdo you know
i guess if you're married or step your
stepdad was your step grandpa
so wait if if his step
if his step-grandpa is also his dad so
it's both his death step oh wait i
thought they were different oh i didn't
even put that together yeah he has two
titles oh no
i should say that all the information
that i i know comes from me being
friends with him and like late 2008
early 2009 so
um give me something bro
give me something come on you called in
work at me i'd drop a nuggie on me
i i i don't feel comfortable doing that
if i don't all right oh
bro we got you on the
line
you know you're coming to my house and
say you know mary but you got nothing to
say well i'ma drive by your house and
tell you a little joke
knock knock guess who's there a gun in
your mouth
funny right
all right thanks for calling uh
appreciate it
we're gonna get get your parents and
then let's have a whole sewing circle
here okay i want to hear everything all
right
thanks so much all right you take care
god bless you
knock knock
guess who's there
a player a pair of plies pliers and a
roll of duct tape
cabish
um
no haters today man it's all love baby
it's all love baby what can you do when
you're this
likable
you know yeah you're so likable i'll
show you likable
but in the good on the good news at
least we gave birth to the wise guy
character
at least something positive could come
out of this debacle jeff thank you ethan
pesci ethan pesci
it's the [ __ ] that'll get you
that's what we should play instead of
the goblins when you're doing the uh
wait didn't we get a claim for that
i don't think we can play it anymore
that song they're claiming that's like
these are out of control we're the only
person playing that song in 2022. you
know somebody on the stat maybe it was
cam
pointed out
that he's actually saying it's the
pictures that'll get you hell no i know
i was so
shook
when i heard this
it said the pictures that again played
again
why the pictures what does that mean
no he's saying [ __ ] i agree but
apparently
look up the lyrics didn't we confirm
that this that was a fake version and
yeah maybe it's edited or something yeah
edited version
that's also fake well we okay we know
he's not playing out your ass it just
sounds like it we figured that out a
while ago he's saying something no
there's another version of the song
that's pg
what's the name of the song again why is
guy why is guy why is he he says
yeah
you can find out
the girls like trash
this is an old meme for people that
don't know but joe pesci put out this
song about being a gangster
and it's so
true
it's so bad and misogynistic and weird
on three websites so far it's the
[ __ ] that'll get you yeah it's not
pictures cameron what is this propaganda
uh
maybe like love so maybe it's like the
edited version did you hear an edited
version camera
i i think he's screening calls so he's
not uh
it's the [ __ ] that'll get ya
we'll have to do some more research
really i do see that too that it's it's
saying on all these lyric sites says
that but uh it says [ __ ] or pictures
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah it's the [ __ ] that
are beautiful that's that then that's
the truth isn't it
that this is that's just what it is
eat out my ass now that
that sounds like it sounds
so much
eat out my ass treat out the girls like
trash
someone said can i please debate both
ethan and abe on their superhero takes
listen i'm not passionate i'll let you
debate a b but i'm not i'm not i don't
care about superhero [ __ ] dude
don't debate me about it
i don't care
but thank you for the 20 nick oh that
was 20 bucks yeah
that's my opinion about superheroes
all right here's a here's a new trend on
tick tock called tiny tick tock
i think it's a joke but dan's taking it
seriously well no i
i said that i agree that most of them
are a joke but it's that doesn't make it
any less [ __ ]
disturbing
i can't play the music but it's like i
guess a tiny voice meme where it's like
i don't
i think it's just some soundcloud song
but i guess maybe i mean you could
upload it real fast and see if it gets
claimed
it's so hard to be such a tiny and small
dentist sometimes when i'm filling a
cavity i fall into it and have to climb
out sometimes i drop the teeth i pull
because they're too heavy for my petite
frame that's weird i don't like that
see i told you it's [ __ ] weird dude
wait hit him with the music real fast
so it's like it's like a fairy filter i
guess
i don't get it man i hate it i hate it
so much
well it's especially confusing it has a
1.5 million views aka
6.4 million
views or i mean likes what i said before
likes yes
right
uh
let's see some primo examples
okay
this one has even more likes i'm so
small and petite this is me trying to
drink a regular bottle of water
okay
let's see it buddy
[Music]
i mean i guess that one is
funny
[Laughter]
these are so [ __ ] disturbing to me i
don't know what it is no it is because
it's like i don't like the whole oh [ __ ]
no
james charles
i told you not to open that one before
the show hell no dude
hi sisters
no no no no no
i'm just so little
[Music]
it's so hard being so small and tiny and
petite even simple tasks like sitting in
a chair or sometimes
or my fragile little body
yeah see don't talk like that like you
lost the right to be talking about
petite tiny
fragile little body this is what i'm
saying dude like there is an
undercurrent to these
youngest i'm sure most most are just
[ __ ] around but there's there's
something
when you got james jumping on the train
james are you what's your type
i'm not physically attracted to older
guys
right
right
i would date like the absolute youngest
right the youngest possible okay that's
not a red flag
you're saying you would date the
absolute youngest possible person
so embarrassing
it is you shouldn't ever say that
publicly
okay cool
i hate him maybe with you know what i
haven't heard him way too long
hit me with the womp womp
oh no
that's not a womp bomb there it
these are all super popular man this one
has half a million likes when you were
born three seconds ago and find out an
adult wolf has a crush on you the [ __ ]
wolf man
you wanna
what what
what does that mean
most of the adult wolf has a crush on a
newborn baby oh what's the context
the top comment is i literally don't
understand this
oh is it a is it a twilight thing i
guess
it's okay can you decide for this baby
when you were born baby
you were born three seconds ago and find
out an adult wolf man has a crush on you
oh okay so yeah because
possibly because i don't know it's a
spoiler can i spoil twilight yeah it's
been out longer
it's been over ten years i think the
wolf character jacob imprints on edward
and bella's daughter
he can't control who he imprints on but
he imprints on what does imprint mean
like
he's forever
uh
i don't know lina how do i how do i
describe in print
like eternally bound to her
he's great sexually yeah he's grooming
her that's what it sounds like lena has
a mic is he wants to mate with her or
like he just wants to be her godfather
well in the movie he's protective of her
but she ages really fast and edward has
a future uh a vision of them in the
future together so
take that as you will how the [ __ ] do
you actually like this movie dude dudes
the movies are so it sounds like the
most disgusting
you know that shit's [ __ ] weird no
it's like it's so bad that like it's
good no don't don't i've always said
that i've always said that what do you
mean
what what do you think i'm like i think
you have evidence to the contrary zach
play it
i like the twilight movie yeah yeah
lena
does she like it because it's bad or
because he likes it
are you talking about batman no i'm
talking about twilight
no i mean
i think he enjoys uh both aspects of it
there's good and
bad mean it's kind of good she says the
story's good good job babe taught her
how to be a politician
yeah she kind of gave an answer she says
he likes the good end about it
some things are good some things are bad
she never sells you out
she doesn't she's the best
she's loyal
she is loyal
lina's loyal
he had saw me out in a
heartbeat expect nothing less though
okay well tiny talk is pretty weird guys
i gotta say yeah
um let's see
here's some more we have a lot of tiny
talk you guys saw this is just
uh someone put me in a seat belt is this
not a kid or is that just the filter
i hate being tiny petite every time i
fart i bounce from my seat literally
defying gravity
so this one is funny 1.8 million
[Music]
is he gonna fart for us oh yeah
[Laughter]
so he's small but his farts are normal
size
i guess or he's just so lightweight that
a little that
but his fart would be small too then oh
that's a good point hmm he's got human
sized
uh
he's all intestines lower intestines
yeah do you guys have an idea for me
should i do a petite
epidemic
what's the filter
do you know that what filter they're all
using to look like that i can find it oh
it's the first thing on my
it popped right up oh well because your
accounts no wait is it they're listening
dude wait it just says the song hang on
i'm not seeing the filter like is it not
available for
me why am i not seeing the filter
i don't know i don't know anything about
how thick talk works anime eyes is it
anime eyes
seems possible
i'm just so small and petite i hope
james charles doesn't message me
okay ready yeah ready
okay all right post it so we can pull it
up and show the audience i am just so
small
and petite i hope oh but you know tik
tok will remove it because they like
protect them let's see how long it takes
yeah really sad i hope james charles
really sad
dude you're gonna get sister sniped
i don't want you to get banned on
tick-tock wow sister schnapped free
speech baby
what the [ __ ] just so small petite i
hope james charles doesn't see this and
message me
i somehow missed i missed this saga
oh you missed that one i didn't see this
one go ahead
your newborn blast yellow diarrhea all
over your clean bed sheets of 4am you
got to play the sound
what's the matter
just hay fever
[Laughter]
i have no idea what that's from
all right guys
live
it's all happening my friends what's up
i am now part of a trend viral you're
going viral baby i will trend you're
small you're a small little guy
all right small bean tick-tock is
live
baby
watch out i'm not seeing it
i just posted it let's see yeah
you're so [ __ ] blacklisted
no they haven't been they haven't been
i'm about to get blacklisted
didn't did you learn your lesson old man
oh i see it you see it
all right i'll give it five minutes
here we go
[Music]
there's a part where my eyes
get all yeah they look glitchy oh god
yeah right there that's disturbing
you have like an inner eyelid yeah i
don't like that
there's this really creepy filter on
tick tock that makes pictures come alive
and it's the oh yeah crazy have you seen
it it's wild
it's cool it is it is weird though for
sure
so mr beast
did this willy wonka [ __ ] where he like
is selling candy bars and there's an
actually an actual gold ticket in them
apparently if you get the gold ticket
you get a chocolate factory
which means he's like i'll just give you
half a million bucks because i don't
think anyone wants a chocolate factory
yeah i mean that's a lot to take on and
like manage
a very good prize
so
people are accusing him of of
of scamming mr reese launched his own
candy bar that allows you to enter
sweepstake oh he's giving over a million
dollars in prizes
hey let's watch the video i guess
i just launched a chocolate bar and 10
random people that buy it will be flown
down to compete in a video for my
chocolate factory it comes in three
different flavors original almond and my
favorite crunch the best part is all our
bars are made with simple high quality
ingredients on top of that we're also
giving away over a million dollars in
prizes and offerings like seadoos super
73 custom pcs beats by dress teslas and
also cash go to feasibles.com and order
some beast bars right now they taste
amazing and you can win some money show
them how peel scan type
[Music]
wait is is that his brand feastable i
feel like i've seen that before
it's a good brand name
is that all him yeah
really feastable it's a great name
what's on his website
yeah they seem to have gone all in on
that
i find it interesting like it just
oh my god
feastable
how has nobody made use that name
already
bro i can't do this
the link to the
candy bar website is in the dark
feast a bill
please let just stay up i don't know why
this keyboard the keys are all crazy now
it says it can't load
feast tables
feast of oh my god i can't type on this
keyboard you guys
i sent in discord
feast a bowl or with a s or what yeah
okay
all right we made it guys
so it's just chocolate he doesn't have
any other feastables yet
chocolate
it's kind of an interesting vertical to
get into
you know
so he's saying
uh other creators have redeemed their
codes into their content however due to
low chances of winning prizes
feastable patrons began to speculate
whether or not the sweepstakes are
rigged
that seems unlikely doesn't it
who's speculating that
dextero dextro talked with feastables
head of production and growth ben aycott
to help clarify why people seem to be
losing so frequently
i mean you're entering like an insane
sweepstake what do you expect the
chocolate you're buying chocolate you
know that's why you should be buying it
not to win feasibles is a number game of
pure chance
customers have started claiming that the
sweepstakes are rigged
because they didn't win because they did
because they bought a hundred chocolate
bars and got nothing you got a hundred
chocolate bars eat the chocolate that's
why you're buying it
uh a cut explains that sweepstakes are
impossible to hack a rig winning a prize
is pure chance and the astronomical
number of bars and codes redeemed make
it highly unlikely you'll win
of the one million prize pool over 440
thousand prizes have been distributed
35 000 people have received prizes
ranging from merch candy bar beast
burger codes
and beats by dre and 10 000 in cash
millions of bars sold in the last five
weeks damn boy
this man is selling chocolate like
what isn't he selling that's true he's
putting willy wonka to shame dude
we should buy some
i'll try it yeah
seems good mr b's chocolate i mean it's
just a chocolate bar how could it be i
mean i've had chocolate i've had a
billion chocolate bars you know what i
mean well you might win that's fun
that'd be awesome people would be so
sketched out
yeah let's buy some of those chocolate
bars let's buy like a thousand of them
what are you working for mr b
what is this yeah i know what the hell
what kind of i want to win i want to
gamble come on
the biggest surprise of all is uh grab
is one of 10 spots in an upcoming mr
beast video
all 10 competitors randomly selected via
feastable sweepstakes and will compete
to own mr b's chocolate factory
dude this man is a genius i can't even
deal with his like marketing
his
the powerhouse of whatever the [ __ ] is
going on in his life
he has an episode on rogan that's
dropping today
okay that's interesting yeah i wonder
how that'll go
i wonder if it's going to be a lot of
like so you make money on youtube
how do you make money on youtube it is
kind of hard to envision what they're
gonna i'm really curious to see if rogan
can connect with him in a meaningful way
right
that gets my dick hard
oh
okay
you know
oh man
i really wanted to talk about tai lopez
is getting absolutely eviscerated online
for his nft schemes
knowledge
knowledge
i don't i haven't really dug into it but
i just see people here i see him
trending on twitter of all the crypto
bros just
absolutely eviscerating him yeah crypto
twitter is calling out tai lopez for his
original garage is that really what he
calling it
yep
you're in my garage
nft influencers have called out the
project for giving the industry a bad
name what ty lopez former coinboys
engineer revealed a shocking fact about
the project's smart contract according
to his screenshots he shared the project
immediately siphons out the funds
into the team members wallets whenever a
user meant to nft
dude that's that's some knowledge bro
you've got knowledge so it's like an
automatic rug pull right
lose lose
but it's an nft what does it matter if
he keeps the money in his wallet
shouldn't it i mean it's not a crypto it
doesn't you know what i mean it depends
what the crypto people or the nft people
has promised to do with the money so
sometimes nft people promise to reinvest
it in marketing and stuff well in his
case
he's trying to do that whole schtick
where it's like if you have the nft you
can uh
come to my exclusive hotel that is only
for holders of the
[Music]
and like the nfts
the garyvee thing you know like the
restaurant or whatever
tai lopez turned into a knockoff tai
lopez
he's a dollar store tai lopez now
gary vee he's got a [ __ ] he's got to be
mad at garyvee garyvee kind of took his
whole stick and just refined it garyvee
dominated the space man yeah
but i saw one where one of the prizes
for
tai lopez nft was
you pay
i think the nft cost
fifty thousand dollars
and then the prize is you get to play ty
lopez one-on-one basketball for a chance
to win ten thousand dollars if you win
that's awesome where's that video of him
saying he crashed the blockchain i saw
everyone goofing on him for that ab he
crashed it he goes yo we crashed the
blockchain
i don't think it works that way dude i
don't understand this though like
genuinely i i just what are we talking
about it says the here's the benefits
the nf if you own one of these nfts it
allows you to hang out with tai lopez
while everybody's running to
for that opportunity
the lineup includes things like getting
his what's up number
watching a movie with him
shadowing him in his office
so in a way it's similar to other person
what the who wants to do any of that
[ __ ] tai
yo if you buy my nft you can get me
coffee for a day
you can get my food for me
here's tai lopez saying they crashed the
uh blockchain
which i don't think you can crash the
blockchain
especially crashed the whole damn
blockchain in like four
took four minutes to crash it slowed it
down completely
you see what i'm saying tai lopez is a
dollar store lopez these days what the
[ __ ] was that
[Laughter]
yeah i mean the blockchain is like a
behemoth of computers across the world
you can't
yeah i i
i'm no expert but
something tells me that that doesn't
well especially in any sense
so this is from selling
that was insane
so i guess yeah is this contradictory to
what he promised it says it's
immediately siphons out the funds when
you mint it
um obviously i don't read code so i'm
just going to trust them on that one
you know
more benefits include
early mint for white list members
started yesterday and the project has
already pulled
uh
97 000 in secondary trade volume
really
so so people are actually buying this
crap
baby maybe
maybe somebody's buying this crap
here's the stats for his whole the og
original garage social club by tai lopez
so the full trade volume
is 105 each so what does that come out
to well it's like 250 000.
yeah i guess around that or give or take
depending on what eth is trading at
right now
man this is people just
people are just buying [ __ ] man it's the
weirdest thing
sometimes with these things though
there's a term for it um because
everything with crypto has to have like
some weird
alternate phrase but we're basically
the people making it
buy it themselves in order to make it
seem like there's more hype for it than
there actually is you don't know if
that's actually what he's doing but
that's a pretty common tactic with these
these nft projects of like to drive up
the price is they basically just
buy and pass them back and forth between
their own accounts for more and more
money so it it seems like whoa this is
like a hot commodity everybody wants
this thing yeah i hear ya
i mean here's some you can see what the
activity is though sure
22 minutes ago this guy dropped 3 500
for a movie with ty and friends by the
way it seems like he's just selling
his courses via the blockchain that
doesn't seem that bad
movie with tai what happens if you why
would you resell that though why would
that have resale value
why would you buy in the first place
og mentor accelerating pass
people are buying that
og nft hotel baby yeah right hotel
restaurant and club membership and that
was a thousand bucks so
yo the nft hotel bro that's gonna be so
dope it's gonna be on an island in uh
fiji or whatever the [ __ ]
i heard it's like underwater
and like there's like
sharks and freaking whales come and say
goodnight to you
yo that's sick
dude it's crazy
nft hotel man
well funded it looks like they have a
thousand dollars funded for that one so
far so
it's gonna be awesome that's enough to
make a hotel
this mentorship pass is going is uh
selling very well
but what's the resale value what am i
missing about this
that crypto [ __ ]
well you know there's selling a lot guys
limited amount of uh
hours in the day for tai lopez to hang
out with you and watch movies and you
know
when demand
demand for that runs out of control
that price that's it's going to the moon
no but can you resell it for a buck and
then he has to hang out with them like
what does that mean yeah i mean i guess
theoretically but every time it resells
he's got to hang out with someone it
doesn't make sense
[Music]
right it seems like the hangout is
probably just a one-time thing and why
the [ __ ] would you want us to resell it
listen man you're asking a lot for
people to have actually thought through
these things that's that's not i'm not
what you do with nfts
i have a feeling there's an answer to my
questions man this is wild dude people
are just buying this [ __ ] i don't know
what's wrong with you i buy one
you should buy one
and see what you get
i don't think i need to pay him to hang
out with
it with ty
pretty sure he would readily come
talk to me there's one movie per year
one movie per year
one meeting per year yeah so it's like a
time share so you buy it
and then he's gotta honor the meeting
yeah so if it was used before you buy it
you'll have to wait a year you have to
wait until next year
that's interesting yeah
i love the idea that thai becomes just
so desirable that these these nfts are
going to become so worth or so valuable
over time
[Music]
yo you get to meet with tai lopez this
year bro i'll pay you a million bucks
for that
do you get to pick the movie or how does
it work
hell no thai pics yeah you can watch
maximum two hours worth of a movie max
two hours [ __ ]
you're getting cut off they actually
specified yeah
you can join him to watch a two-hour
two-hour movie why would you so if he's
your mentor
why the [ __ ] would you want to sit
quietly and walk what does that
accomplish oh
that's the dumbest thing don't you want
to talk to him i just want to be in your
presence dude
god it's so valuable
that what's really gonna happen is this
things are gonna become worthless and
then tai lopez can really know what a
other piece of [ __ ] is
he's like yo people won't pay 10 bucks
to hang out with me
i wonder if all those lawyers will be
there for the hangout looking in your
html
i wonder if they own a token though
because they're there with a stopwatch
to make this right the movie's over two
hours
they just cut it
off it's not even finished thanks for
joining us
i'm gonna have to send you out on your
way
please enjoy this seat it turns into a
cartoon catapult
[ __ ] injects you when the timer ends
if you if you look at the long run he
gets paid very little per hour if he has
to watch a two-hour movie every year
forever
right
um there's several on here though
there's probably right yeah so that gets
like 2.5 k
that's gonna go down
so that's 1k
an hour every year and if it goes more
than a year it's like 500 an hour right
it keeps going down
he's going to stop honoring that next
year i don't think he'll do it uh more
than once yeah
well i think ty genuinely thinks that's
going to go up to like a million bucks
well i don't know maybe maybe it will i
mean that's that's a valuable two hours
right there
hey hey you're in the movie theater hey
i wanted to ask you about shh
i'm watching
no talking in the theater what's wrong
with you man
hey i wanted to ask you about that
oh tai lopez nfd collection gives access
to the exclusive mentor social club and
claims to provide a lot of benefits like
sitting in a dark theater and not being
able to talk
ty is also giving a chance to win a
board eight
oh he's like yo if you buy my [ __ ] you
can buy and actually but you can might
buy absolutely value for some money
you might went aboard ape to early
holders no way
[Laughter]
it's specified on the nft that you are
responsible to cover all travels food
and accommodations so you got to pay for
the stuff yo you yeah you want some
popcorn all right that's like what eight
bucks so
i have a square you can just run your
card oh my god that's so funny
hey this is uh some nft guy hey uh tai
lopez legit question why would i pay 30
to 40 000 to watch a movie with you
or 80 to 90 000 for whatsapp who do you
think you are you def have a shady
reputation and doing this only adds more
fuel to the fire i respect anyone
wanting to add value to nfts but this is
not the way well it's really not that
different than what most of these guys
wait price is 45 eth one on one shadow
tie in his and in person at his office
45 eth how much is that
that'd be a lot i mean
right now is
heath price
it is about 2500 just a little under
it's 113k
to be his intern to be his unpaid intern
wait hold on this is my favorite
one-on-one michelin star restaurant with
tai but according to the terms and
service you gotta pay for the meal
yeah
that's funny
one-on-one what's up access to tai can
you imagine those conversations be like
you know leave you on read for a day
he has a 30 section
uh what's it called like
terms of service
so i'm sure in this term
service he can like deny in it any
whatever like try to look for some
nuggies in there yeah i'm looking
how about this one-on-one private jet
trip with ty
where to where to do what just fly on
the airplane
do i have to pay for my ticket just
circle around the airport yeah like what
are you talking about
what are you doing
wait i got to see the price someone sent
me this page i want to see the
all the benefits somebody in the chat
suggested
you get a one-on-one tickle fight with
ty
that'd be worth more than some of the
things he's actually offering
i mean is this is this a desperation
play is his whole like mentorship
program
falling off you know
i have to it seems a little desperate i
i think he's just wants to because he
sees how much money gary v is making
right and i think he just wants a piece
of the
piece of the pie yeah
yeah i suppose so
yo a one-on-one pecking session with ty
see these are better ideas than what he
came up with our chats coming up with
some give ty a prostate exam yeah
or ty could give you a prostate exam
um
original garage dot com let me check out
this i love these nft projects man these
will go down in history yeah thank you
let's see what ty's got for us
okay here we go this is exciting
let's go from high
high to low let's see the most valuable
ones
accelerator pass 38 who's what the [ __ ]
you talking about
play basketball
now why the [ __ ] would i pay twenty
eighth
to play basketball with some middle-aged
little goon
why play back don't you want to learn
from him why would you want to play bad
he's not shaq
50 grand to shoot some hoops with the
yeah that's what he's saying and you can
win 10 000 if you beat him right at a
horse
by the way they only created two nft
graphics too just like a gold card and a
silver card
so if i made one of these what do you
think i could like if someone was like
uh play
uh
counter strike with ethan for
five hours can you imagine i'll [ __ ]
just still over it by then how much do
you think someone would pay for that
five hours from gaming with ethan a lot
more than tai lopez
oh yeah
a b be the top bidder
i definitely think you're worth a lot
more than tai lopez yeah i wouldn't do
that though it's embarrassing it's
humiliating
also it's like just icky to make a fan
pay to hang out with you
it's like all right so what do you want
to do now kid that's so awkward thanks
for the hundred thousand what the [ __ ]
you want to do with me now
all right well get get the [ __ ] out now
that you think we're friends i'll never
talk to you again well time's up you got
it
push on out
we're gonna head upstairs are all like
all act super friendly and like we're
having a good time and then once the
timer expires i just smile goes off my
face and i just leave without saying a
word and then someone else comes in and
says thank you for thank you there's the
door yeah
you should call yourself an uber
yeah we don't provide the
transportation so
it says here's section 21 we will not be
liable for any delay or failure to
perform our obligations under these nft
terms if such delays due to any
circumstance beyond our reasonable
control
like what
anything tai got a flat tire and then
lasted a couple here but it's basically
like
pandemic for example
is in there oh well that's convenient
yeah
during a pandemic
damn i couldn't fulfill any of these you
guys oh man i can't get on a jet with
you wearing a pandemic
somebody uh in a donor just said um i am
currently taking bets on how long before
ryan cavanaugh enters the nft scam space
he already did
well that's what i was gonna say yeah
they've been stealing boy do i have news
for you yeah check out triller nft
brian kavanagh is the force of nature
all right here let's talk to i have a
hater
on the on the line we have a few so john
says he used to be a fan of me during
humongous days
and now i drive him crazy because i've
gone too far in the other direction john
what do you mean i've gone in the other
direction what do you mean by that
uh first of all what's up
thanks for calling thank you for calling
you know you uh i'm gonna i i literally
peterson
you got it so wrong wait sorry sorry you
cut off you kind of cut you cut out for
all i heard was peterson so maybe
yeah yeah you heard right okay so this
is my thing like uh
i'm from canada ontario so i am not a
jordan peterson fan i promise you that
okay
but
he
he is not pro-conversion therapy
the way you framed that was so gutless
and it's the way you attack the right
like the way you attack the right and
say they half truth it you totally did
that okay because
that whole thing is about
i mean up here we're a little different
conservatives up here aren't crazy
[ __ ] i gotta say it right
so i'm a bit of a conservative certainly
liberally minded but
you know it's about value value
grandstanding and the fact that our you
know our country's going through some
stuff right now
it's all
it's not a thing that happens here so so
it was an empty
piece of legislation that the media just
goes oh we love it we love it and you
just so you know like you're doing the
same thing you hate to see the right do
and that [ __ ] kills me cause you used
to be in the center you really did like
your humongous stuff calling out you
know like uh
white face for instance like
you were on the right track and in the
last couple years you've gone just
completely to the left
so you're disappointed that i've gone to
the left
and so and may i ask to clarify i'm
disappointed in the hypocrisy hold on a
second
you
are saying that what
it was incorrect about ethan dunking on
jordan peterson
tweet here it is right now conversion
therapy more moral grandstanding from
the juvenile om justin trudeau
here
conversion therapy wasn't a thing that
even happened in canada so by him
saying that it's banned now he was just
trying to score points is that am i
understanding that correctly
percent dan as you usually do
okay and i just wanted to make sure i
understood the argument because i was a
little confused for a second so like i i
just mean it no like dan your taste
usually i'm fully on board with lately
ethan it's hard to listen to you
sometimes man they'll love you what's
interesting because i i consider myself
significantly more left than than ethan
you know that right
are you going somewhere damn with that
you know what's funny
what the analysis so wait sorry
well
i was just trying to correctly i wanted
to understand his argument correctly uh
uh that
that he's saying that you got it
conversion therapy wasn't a thing in
canada and so
jordan peterson no calling it out
was just him saying that justin trudeau
was virtuous okay guys so you're saying
there was no conversion therapy in the
whole country of canada nowhere it
didn't exist i can't obviously i can't
speak to that allegedly allegedly
allegedly i can't so you're saying to me
right now some catholic backyard you're
telling me
that justin trudeau coming out
and saying conversion therapy is a bad
thing
we're saying it now we're saying it was
a joke it's a [ __ ] fraud like it's
why does that bother you
why does it bother you that that justin
trudeau is making that statement i
that's not what bothered me it bothered
me that you used the same pattern no no
no tell me what bothered you about what
justin trudeau said first
trudeau trudeau makes a big deal out of
these things like for instance
indigenous schools indigenous water
supply guess what there's no water still
guess what you know what bothered you
about what he said about conversion
therapy
what did trudeau say sorry i i lost you
for a second there
what bothered you
about what justin trudeau
said about banning conversion therapy
i don't know our health care systems are
[ __ ] what bothered you
you're not answering my question
why don't you keep talking about other
things there's bigger more important
things going
on can't talk about one thing and not
care about others so your point is that
because justin trudeau
said that convergent therap now let me
talk you called in
you wanted to you wanted to sit you're
right okay now let me talk i wanna i
wanna stick to one thing thank you
now your point is
conversion therapy a disgusting practice
which tells people that gay people are
born wrong and they need to be fixed
and tudo saying that it's now banned in
canada is makes you disgusted because
there's more important things to address
did i did i understand your point
correctly no
okay then what bothered you about this
tweet
it's you that bothers me ethan no you
you're watching you dance around the
fact you know nothing about what's going
on up here so what did i get wrong peter
said what kind of conversion therapy
he is not co-conversion therapy no one
in canada is oh no one here okay so the
whole country of canada there's not one
person in favor of conversion there's
generalizing obviously obviously i'm
generalizing look okay so let's let's
just you said justin trudeau made you
sick with this tweet did you not
no
you made me sick that's what i've been
trying to say this whole time i didn't
care about what trudeau tweets okay the
fact that you jumped on peterson okay
and you're like
you put words in his mouth and you
criticize the writers
okay so i'm trying to save you let's
just work this one piece at a time
so you have no problem with justin
trudeau said okay
you think that what justin who said is
good we're banning conversion therapy
great
i think it was a value standing i do i
do think it was i know it was that's how
he's gotten elected here three elections
in a row you know i've worked on
parliament hill straight up this is this
is
real stuff
so okay so you're not you're kind of
tiptoeing around if you have a problem
with this tweet or not you say not i'm
just going to take your word for it okay
so now the waste of time i think it's a
waste of time to tweet it that's that'd
be my god forbid to make a tweet
what a wait what a colossal waste of
time he could have uh he could have
gee in that 10 seconds what he could
have done so much for the country
to to make a statement and say we are
against conversion therapy a horrendous
homophobic practice shame on justin
trudeau for putting his neck out there
and saying that he could have been uh
god he could have uh he could have
what could he have done with 10 10
seconds it's unbelievable okay so anyway
you take that you you you support his
justin trudeau so now let's move on to
jordan peterson okay
ah excuse me i just choked a goat
i'm related went down the wrong pipe
give me a sec
sorry stan stand by joe so jordan
peterson says
quote
conversion therapy
more moral grandstanding from our
juvenile
i don't know what the [ __ ] om is the
prime minister what is om
i mean i know he's the piano sorry i
don't know if i got cut off there yeah
everything hung up on me but either way
i understand
i hate that i'm this hostile just so you
know they'll respect the hello to you
just want to say that no why you can't
hear me
no why you can't hold me
i can hear myself i can hear you now i
can hear you so let's talk about me yeah
i can hear you now
all right so let's talk about jordan's
tweet now he says quote
okay conversion therapy
and he puts it in quotation marks which
implies like it's not a real thing
that's what air quotes mean right
he's gotta mute his stream yeah you you
you gotta meet your story your stream
buddy
okay i just i closed my computer it's
not it's not even on but uh sorry about
that guys here all good it's all good
now it's better
so he says
no i can still hear are you on
speakerphone
no i'm just on on my phone maybe i'll
turn it down a bit
so it says quote conversion therapy
i didn't hear the echo before
are you doing so you got speaker you got
something up
i just muted it while you're speaking
that that'll solve it while i'm trying
to figure out what's happening
quote conversion therapy
now the the quotations makes he's he's
basically downplaying the seriousness of
conversion therapy
more moral grandstanding from our
juvenile
president justin trudeau
now explain why what jordan peterson
said here is uh
is good tell me why i am wrong to
criticize this man
you aren't wrong to criticize
fundamentally i'm onto the same page
with you it is disgusting
what you did wrong ethan is you did the
same thing tucker carlson would do which
is you were lazy and you just said oh
he's jordan peterson he's obviously
anti-gay he's obviously this it wasn't
about that it was about you know the
political divide in canada that's going
on that frankly you probably have no
understanding right
so
he so tell me what he meant then because
he has conversion therapy and quotes is
it moral grandstanding to be against
conversion therapy because i don't think
so i think that's a good
that's a good place to be that's not
moral grandstanding that's like good
standing is it redundant
okay let's say
i mean does it not buggy let's put it
this way does not bug you it's not like
being like right
isn't that being like
yo we just passed the freedom to vote
act
because we think that the
black neighborhood should same have the
same access to voting as affluent
neighborhoods you go oh nice moral
grandstanding caring about people voting
i don't see the problem
with
saying something that's objectively good
that there's plenty of [ __ ] people in
the world that need to hear are you
telling me there's no homophobes in
canada right now are there homophobic
people in canada
of course so what the [ __ ] is wrong with
the head of state saying we support gay
people's right to exist
nothing ethan i was telling you so how
is that moral grandstanding then
i it's it is still moral grandstanding
because that's how he is elected here i
don't know if you understand the
politics up here oh okay so same good
things is moral grand study there's only
been four conservative governments in
the history of canada like straight up
poor majorities anyways anyways
like i'm telling you
people here are annoyed by trudeau he's
annoying he is little mr goody two-shoe
i love everything it's it's he does
meanwhile our economy is so [ __ ] our
health care system can't handle 30
people per hospital it's it's a joke and
we're doing huge press conferences about
something that's already illegal it's
just redundant
it's very redundant so you're telling me
so what's conversion
before this bill was passed okay so i've
been looking up some stuff and i found
an article from 2020 in the vancouver
sun i i don't know anything about the
vancouver sun i don't know if that's
considered a reputable uh newspaper or
anything like that that a study found
[Music]
that in 2020
that
uh conversion therapy was still
commonly used in canada uh let's see
well hold on this guy says that it
didn't exist in the whole country uh
i mean again i i don't know what about
the vancouver sun i can't speak to how
reputable this is i was just doing some
initial googling about you know stats of
conversion therapy in canada but uh as
of a few years ago it did appear to be a
thing that was still in practice in some
parts of canada well that's impossible
right john
or whatever yeah john
all right you got me you got me i
embellished i i
you know
okay so didn't you just do what tucker
carlson does it's already didn't you
call him to say that i embellish and
that i'm a part of the media gotcha
whatever but you just called in and
embellished and said conversion therapy
doesn't exist therefore it's moral
grandstanding so
going back to the original part do you
think it's world grandstanding to
[ __ ] ban conversion therapy one of
the most disgusting homophobic acts that
can be done on gay people agreed okay so
what's the [ __ ] problem ontario
already by the way i never said jordan
pearson hates gay people i said he says
conversion therapy is moral
grandstanding which is verbatim what he
said no you said he's pro conversion
therapy look it up it's in one of your
blair white bits well i'm sure you know
i watch you a lot dude i'm a huge fan
like just so you know like i'm i it's
crazy i'm arguing with you this hard
right now but okay i am a huge fan okay
thank you maybe i did say that i don't
remember it's possible but like he's not
against it it doesn't sound like he's
against it
like why the [ __ ] would he choose this
tweet to go oh moral grandstand well and
what i think is interesting is i i would
think that
the
this point about it being moral
grandstanding would make more sense if
he was just making a tweet making a
generalized statement of like conversion
therapy is wrong and we need to do
something about it right but that's not
what the tweet is it's actually saying
an announcement that it's an eff
official they passed a bill banning it i
think that it's i don't think it you can
really justifiably call that moral
grandstanding if you're actually taking
an action well in this case well it
wouldn't waste the time the tweet he
could have he could have uh taken one
step
he could have taken a piss instead
there's so many users
people could have done
this time they make a tweet about a law
that just passed i think the argument
falls apart when when
when there actually is some some uh
concrete action that's been taken
against
uh conversion therapy ask you a question
do you think that this tweet by jordan
peterson was proper do you think this
was the right time to accuse justin
trudeau as much as he hates him as a
moral grandstander peterson fan
but i i am a fan of you ethan and i
expected you and maybe it's not fair
higher higher level
because this is what you get mad at and
this is what i love you call
conservatives that are
doing [ __ ] and it's like lazy right
but it's also lazy
for some of the stuff that the left does
right and that's what i'm trying to say
i think you used to nail it when you
were more centered and that's what this
calls all about right right and in
general i find that the people who i'm
not trying to you know you know what i'm
like i'm not i'm not trying to say
converse like anyways
i find that the people who are uh
disillusioned with me or whatever who
can't are people who
feel like i used to represent their
ideas better and now that i've kind of
come out more as a liberal and against
this kind of [ __ ] that uh people feel
like i'm not one of them anymore and i
feel like you're embodying that i'm glad
you're still able to watch though you
know i thank you for watching i do
appreciate that you're a fan
but i'm calling but i'm calling to have
an argument
yeah yeah yeah anyways look guys it was
[ __ ] awesome debating with you guys
i just want you to know like i joe
rogan's a joke
i take the center all the way i'm george
orwell all the way and so i don't really
have a side and i i like you better when
you're in the center but i still love
you dude
you know i i you know jordan peterson
was even going at me on twitter
and i even said specifically
do you support conversion therapy yes or
no and he did not take the opportunity
to correct the record i don't think it's
a good time
he's a coward okay well there we go
there we agree
maybe if i said he's pro-conversion
therapy that was assuming too much
but i don't think it's a far stretch to
say
you know he's not against conversion
therapy right
if he's calling it moral grandstanding i
think that implies that he thinks it's
it has some value
right i don't think it's a stretch to
say that i think i think
i honestly i want to concede and give it
to you i may not even 100 agree but dude
you make a good point i was just trying
to show you just watch out for for the
hypocritical lane you know that's all i
would say as a fan well i've never said
that i'm pro uh conversion i'm a hater
and a hater
no i'm talking about your tactics and
versus what you chirp what you and
hassan to be honest with you
you know but it's like you're doing the
same thing brother i don't think so but
i appreciate the call-in okay everything
i say i 100 believe
and including this stage
and including this statement john that's
right i love you
oh
thank you brother thank you dude that
was awesome you guys have a great one
all right thanks for calling take care
thanks john
i don't see it
well so i i do remember you
harping on the fact that you kept saying
jordan peterson is pro-conversion
therapy right okay so but but i don't
think that's a it's a stretch it's maybe
it's but it's not that much of a stretch
right he clearly
sees value in it if he thinks banning it
is moral grandstanding right or that you
know it or yeah that it's not valuable
to
take action he doesn't think the
argument is is totally different if he's
just doing one of those useless
politician tweets where it's just like
we need to do this and it's just kind of
like thank you promises that's a great
but in this case he's
he's done something about it you can't
call that grandstanding i mean that that
that's that's a
concrete action that's been taken
that's this is the thing that i've
noticed on the right
anytime you care about anything
god forbid
social like social issues specifically
it's moral grandstanding
you can't care about anything without
mor without being a moral grandstander
you have to be a passive
uh a cons a reactionary to never moral
grandstand you have to be passively
watch as people get uh systematically
discriminated against
that's what good citizens do
coconuts and barbados
[Laughter]
okay that was fun though and i don't
want to discourage other people from
calling in like that because um
you know i think there's some people
here but i can't say i'm terribly
excited to have this conversation
someone wants to push back on ethan fat
shaming i don't know what you're talking
about i'm
i'm uh
i don't know what they're talking about
fat shaming wants to i guess maybe i
should take it uh wants to argue with
ethan being too hard on demi lovato i i
don't care
i left that yogurt
i mean get the yogurt she's still
recovering from the yogurt shop and then
i had a hard time the rest of the
weekend
maybe i'll talk to
adriana who wants to talk about i see i
have a problem with fat shaming
adriana what's what's my problem talk to
me
uh ethan i've been a fan for a while i
actually came from trish and started
watching you guys thank you um
i've been struggling with like my own
body image for a while so i guess
just
i don't know maybe i'm a snowflake
especially after listening to the last
conversation i was like
maybe
even close to what i should be debating
but um
yeah i don't know i think i don't know
you verbally like
frown upon it i think and i think
there's a lot of like young viewers
especially like people that are
developing into their bodies so i think
it's just important to
be aware of that stuff are you who am i
fat shaming myself or someone else
uh i like even even you i think uh to
normalize like
putting your own body image down is not
necessarily the best thing either so
wait wait who am i fat shaming
yourself okay so you're talking about
my
my open deprecation of myself for being
fat
is not healthy for people to see
i think i think to an extent yes um i
think it's nice to be like
i don't know to
i guess say your struggles but to
constantly
no i don't think so
so what would you like so so so should i
i need to be nicer to my i just need to
not acknowledge that i'm a fat [ __ ]
lard ass
no i just i just think it's important to
take it into consideration um
that's all i just
just coming from like being an older
sister and stuff like my little sister
watches you and
i don't know just figured i'd reach out
and say that so do you think so i love
watching the mukbangs though don't stop
those shits oh [ __ ]
see you're trying to be a feeder you're
trying to make me plump
hey
nourished nurse ethan oh girl don't fool
yourself there ain't no nourishment
better at our weight
in
ten pounds of jobs i think jack is
slightly um under-appreciated so
wow
but you feel underappreciated
i don't feel underappreciated i feel
like yeah
i'm having crazy deja vu i feel like
we've had it kind of made me sad when uh
zach wasn't like able to play the video
games with the rest of you guys
definitely hurt my heart a little bit
zach is underappreciated oh but that's
his choice
we would we don't happily have zach
he's just he's not a he's not a freaking
epic gamer like the rest of us i will
say adriana i love that you're a fan but
you may be a little sensitive for the
show
you know i know but i hope but you know
no offense uh
it's okay to be fat i mean i listen but
you can't stop me from hating myself i
mean i'm sorry but that's just never
gonna happen okay
i'm not gonna make fun of that i'll try
not to fat shame others but you can
never stop me from fat shaming myself
okay
all right i love you ethan i love you
guys thanks so much thanks adrian love
you too take care bye love you you're
the greatest that ever did it
okay fun good times eh good times should
i talk to the girl who thinks i've been
too hard on demi lovato
be interesting i kind of just intrigued
this is just off the wall sasha are you
a demi lovato fan
dude
i thought you were just going to end the
show on me nope i'm here for you
go ahead
i'm here for you
no i'm not a fan um
it bugs me because you've been you've
been telling the story wrong and so it
makes me wonder
would you
not make the jokes if you knew the
correct story
right
okay i swear
[Laughter]
are you calling in all right tell me
this tell me the correct story
um
okay so um it's funny you were just
talking about fat shaming right so
demi was just like she was
annoyed that all of the diet stuff was
at the front of the store
and so she left because she's like she's
been fat shamed her entire life is dying
food fat shaming now food is having diet
foods
well also i don't think it was diet food
i think it was like for diabetics it was
like sugar-free [ __ ] that
right but she did not realize that
that's why she made the apology okay
wait wait wait wait wait
sasha hold on i really gotta i gotta
break something
it's what
sasha sasha emphasis on the a yes
sasha
sasha
okay
forgive me forgive me i love you
all right wait so so you're so okay no i
understood the story but i think we're
seeing it differently having diet food
is fat shaming
well
kind of i mean she was just talking
about diet culture you know it's
[ __ ] everywhere and
like we're both heavy me and you
and it can get annoying if you're female
if you've been fat shamed your entire
life like since like i was having diet
food you know
how is having diet food
fat shaming you i just
i can't i can't understand that
first of all again she didn't realize it
was a diabetic thing okay forget about
that let's just assume it's diet food
right so here's the second end of my
argument she is newly sober or was when
she made the post right
i'm newly sober too you know i'm going
on like seven years hard stuff
and for the first like five years i
purposely gained weight i said i'm not
going to think about anything other than
like being happy
and so i feel like you know we were on
the same level and so i got it i just
understood why she made it it's just
like stupid what 10 second post right no
but the effect of her post was that she
she like called this place out by name
and sent like a mob of hate because they
dared to have diet food that's that's
crazy how is having diet food fat jam
you still haven't explained that
it's a product that some people consume
maybe she didn't she could go [ __ ]
get the normal [ __ ] just walk by it i
mean if you're gonna get offended by
diet food how can you exist in this
world how can you even breathe without
being offended by the sunshine because
you're pale i don't understand that how
can you live your life being offended by
diet food that seems to take [ __ ] way
too far
i think she was just okay she shouldn't
have called them out i don't care about
her now i'm asking you so hard on her
considering
you know you could maybe understand was
saying you know
hey like can we just chill it with the
diet [ __ ] you know well i was i
think people were mostly pissed at
how she like sent a horde of hate on
this tiny little
mom and pop you guys certainly are
no i think that was the reaction of the
internet sasha i mean sasha you're
probably over it
so do you get offended when you see diet
food in the store
i don't know i don't really get offended
but if it's everywhere i look if i'm
having a bad day and it seems like it's
everywhere i look
i might you know
i might i want to say something i would
probably do a facebook post about it you
know what i mean
you probably would too oh hell no i
wouldn't you really think so
look at this [ __ ] diet food
everywhere for taking my call at least
we had it out
okay this is interesting but i feel like
we could dig into the psychology of this
whole diet food aversion thing a little
bit more if you want to
thank you
i feel like it's
it's a discussion to be had do what you
want to discuss
let's let's um let's ham it out i don't
know okay so uh
so as a fat as a fellow fatty
i feel like
get mis if you get angry at seeing diet
food your misplacing the frustration and
anger you have with yourself for being
fat
well you would say with my mother
because that's who i could really get
mad at because she she would have me
like suck in my stomach
that's gross like 12 years old yeah it's
really i'm telling you but i sound like
your mom you don't know what it's like
for some people
no i don't i i get it man yeah but like
don't you think like if you if you're
outwardly angry at the world for having
diet food i'm out of the angry but you
know we're like
like i said i would probably make a
facebook post about it i'm also angry at
like coffee companies we're not
companies but like
you know drinking coffee with your
children like are you angry at yourself
at all though
are you angry at so many things ethan at
yourself
um yeah on occasion sure
right because i'm frustrated with myself
i i always feel like weak
or unable to because i really want to
lose weight but i feel like i'm just
incapable i just i just had lacked the
willpower i just i don't know i'm
constantly frustrated but it seems to me
if you're if you're going to be getting
mad at seeing diet food it's probably a
manifestation of your disappointment or
anger at yourself for not having the
you know the control or whatever
to
i just lost like 20 pounds okay good for
you um it but it was never really an
issue for me it was a childhood thing
you know i got chubby at an early age
and then it just sticks to you you know
you're a little bit different
i'm different kind of fatty
yeah i'm the kind of fatty so
wait let me break that down ethan i
think you're so much cuter at this
weight can i do it as a chick i think
you're so much cuter than like pictures
i see of you okay but you know what i
like uh
sasha
sasha i like sasha she's a good she's my
favorite caller yet my friends call me
splash
slash hell yeah
yeah so slash says that i'm i'm
different because i got fat
right slashes she was fat from birth
so i'm on the it sounds like i'm a like
a more pathetic fatty than her because i
chose that you did it by choice yeah
that by choice you already have like a
medication thing uh you know what i mean
yeah we've talked about the whole weight
thing with the yeah
you don't have to worry
you know what slash i'm gonna make a
move in here today
no more diet food
[ __ ] the diabetes too [ __ ] them
they should have their own stores
they should have their own store so
enough to see their [ __ ] ass diet food
all right slash you take care
thanks for saying i'm cute
thanks for calling in
all right bye
and then i had a hard time the rest of
the weekend i cannot when she when she
said that she thinks you look cute at
this size everybody started spamming the
ila cop emoji
in the chat
yo she did sound just like demi lovato i
swear crazy
i swear as soon as she started talking i
was like
because he had just played the uh the
demi clip so i had it in my mind yeah no
you're so right
you know um i can't defend the yogurt
antics i can't
yeah i didn't get yogurt and i just i
ruined my whole week
my wife went out for yogurt without me i
had a hard time the rest of the weekend
oh boy well that was fun uh we have been
going for two and a half hours
yeah let's call it a day okay
keem starts fighting with people on our
subreddit we can save that for next week
we'll save all the good stuff for next
week snoop dogg snoop dogg joins faze
clan board of directors
so now
that's a real thing faze snoop
he is a pro gamer i mean i've seen he
you know pro gamer move to leave your
stream on for 24 hours [ __ ]
oh you're talking about that one that's
right oh he has a bunch yeah no he's a
pro gamer i mean he's definitely fake i
think the one where he rage quits and
[ __ ] throws his controller and [ __ ]
of course they added that clip in his
reveal video
oh they use that yeah they're kind of
self-aware yeah they have to make fun of
it yeah
oh boy you know
somebody
didn't
there was a clip
on the sub of
keemstar seemingly admitting that he is
a part owner of phase
show me you guys pick up on that yeah i
saw that very very surprisingly man that
that dude don't
but i thought it was interesting because
that's been a topic of discussion on
here
whether or not he
it i i saw it over the weekend it just
just hit me uh yeah i had seen that let
me see if i can find it real quick um
you got it all right maybe
let's see came in mexico owns phase
let's see he's so desperate for the
recognition though he's always wearing
phase everything
if he really had any
interest they would name him in like the
press and stuff
right i mean it is and they're about to
they're trying to go public right
like yeah that would have to be a
million dollars on it as a co-owner of
faith no one is going to with you ever
again you pieces of
wait what there's missing content yeah
i'll uh put a million dollars on it as a
co-owner of phase no one is going to
he's referencing something else he's
referencing the fight over the weekend
there was a face member face temper who
fought some dude and he lost dude
or keemstar thinks it's rigged or a lot
of people actually do most people do
and i guess that's what i was rigged
yeah
and i think it's like a general
like most people think it was rigged i
haven't seen it but i really don't think
people are rigging these [ __ ] fights
at the very least a bad decision on the
judges for sure a lot of people are
saying that i'm saying babies are boxing
uh i am an expert nowadays yeah i didn't
watch it personally but i'm seeing my
whole timeline on all spectrums of the
internet are saying uh so calling it out
for being rigged what was this fight
that happened over the weekend i i've
missed the contest it was like
versus wasabi
um in the uk that was the headline fight
oh so it was just a deji fight yeah
which apparently he lost again i know
he's like zero and three
i like that g you know i know it's like
it's just but it's sad it's just getting
sad yeah at this point dude maybe maybe
just not cut out he has a whole losing
cycle where he loses
he cries ksi like says the meanest [ __ ]
you can imagine about him in public then
he fights again same thing over
there's a third time i can't believe
he's still in for the humiliation did
ksi [ __ ] on him yet i i don't know how
did you know that he had a song called
no more else
one more l
one more hell that should have been good
oh that's rough somebody just donated
twenty dollars and said sending good
vibes to lena and then the a b thumbs up
emoji there you go lena are you there
why does lin why are they worried about
lena or something i don't think
everybody's worried because of the uh
the conversation last week
yeah we uh she has an appointment on
friday so oh yeah [ __ ] i'm such
it's on friday we'll know that we'll
know soon
on the plus side uh if people didn't
pick up on it um
cam and therefore also love uh they're
back today back in the office fully
recovered yep we still have him wearing
a mask just to be sure but um he hasn't
had a symptom in over a week he's
feeling fine so uh we gotta we got the
whole fam back in back in the building
except for olivia but and cam has a mic
now
cameron has a mic here's a mic we set up
yeah mike's for uh alternative cam
not yet we're capped out on the number
of cameras we can uh we can add but sam
cam and lena all have mics out there now
so if they ever need to chime in
here let's watch this mark my words show
star mark my [ __ ] words
we no american nobody in face clan
no one will ever work with you ever
again mark my [ __ ] word everybody
cares what you have to say put a million
dollars on it as a co-owner of face no
one is going to [ __ ] with you ever again
oh oh like like he has some influence
he
with that context it does appear to be
that he's saying as a co-owner of phase
no one will ever [ __ ] with you ever
again i'd like for him to disclose his
ownership
of faith looks like he's shooting that
video in hell
yeah okay [ __ ]
well it's his basement so close enough
pieces of [ __ ]
mark my words showstar mark my [ __ ]
words
me no american nobody in
that's where he's never mentioned that
before and then now all of a sudden it's
as a member as a co-owner of face clan
no i'll make sure with my incredible
influence that nobody ever works with
you again
yeah it's weird i don't know
i get feeling that he wouldn't lie about
something like that though so why is he
now just throwing that out there i feel
like he would have said it every second
right
maybe he bought himself in when he knew
it was going to come become public or
something man they wouldn't take his
money
you know they've had a pretty long
lasting relationships ever since they
started so i think i mean it's very
possible i mean is it just that he
didn't disclose it because he didn't
want to appear
[Music]
biased when like rep you know he was
always reporting on the other
like antics on dramaalert not that he
cares about journalistic integrity or
anything but i don't know
maybe that would be a reason could be
yeah
ever work with you ever again mark my
[ __ ] since i just look at keemstar
tweets and see oh yeah here rigged
you are 20 years old and still a virgin
you are 40 and date women two times
younger than you
i think he got you bro
he's arguing with people saying he's 40
and dating fluent yep i think that's a
dub
um cool yeah let's not oh interesting
donation
even though me and keem share a birthday
it's always nice to know his birthday is
on international women's day
oh that's a beautiful touch of iron yeah
between your legs cameron grant member
for 20 months why am i still paying for
my membership wait for real
thank you bro that's so meaningful
thank you so much that's [ __ ]
happening man i have so many repeating
membership things by now i i'm i can't
even imagine how much i'm paying that i
don't even remember that i'm paying
you know oh just for like various
services and yeah
should audit that you're probably right
i don't even know how to audit it
because we'll just look through your
like banking statement and see if
there's nothing like we're insane
because it's all like on business okay
and oh right
the invoices are crazy i got you i can
ask our accountant to be like yo can you
spot all the maybe that'd be a fun
segment where i bring all the repeating
subscriptions that i don't use
descriptions for some service from like
10 years ago that you've been paying for
i'm sure there's a lot i'm sure probably
yeah i just realized i'm a 20 month as
well
you are
wow
a b i'm so touched
was that that must have been when we
like really launched it officially and
started pushing but you were working
here already weren't you no i worked
right after oh you sucked oh yeah i'm
also 20 months oh my goodness dan what
month are you
what month dan
go ahead dan which month are you are you
19
i don't think i don't think i'm a paying
member coconuts barbados
yeah well i'm actually subscribed to on
three accounts i just noticed
maybe i am actually let me let me check
maybe i subscribed and forgot i might be
an example you might be one of them yes
uh
i think dan has that 20-month job is a
membership oh
well how many months
here it is uh
how do you see that actually um
a street podcast five dollars a month
manage
just a quick note ethan i'm one is that
on the business card uh am i paying
myself there dan oh that would be funny
that's gotta be that let me check what
zack i am one year two months ago
yeah that's cool it's on my personal wow
[Music]
i'm sending one of those messages right
now it is
dan is sending his message 12 months 12
months baby wow what a team ian what
month are you
ian i don't know i'd have to look i am
subscribed you are i can't believe so
here's the thing that's crazy here's the
thing
to access the member content to like
check the comments and everything you
can only see it if you're a member so i
believe that you all have signed up you
should put it on the business card yeah
that's actually a good point i might
change that over
i'm actually surprised you guys are
actually subscribed that's funny yeah if
you're doing it for work put on the
business card look at all these people
doing it now
wow another 20 minutes
rubber chicken that is a flex thank you
to all the members you guys actually
make a huge difference so really do
really appreciate that yeah it makes
makes a huge huge difference
16 months three months 12 months 19
there's a 19 a six say their name down
it's gonna help so uh kirsten landry
raven am and don't forget not only
should you sign up for a membership but
you should like subscribe hit that bell
and share this video
oh i want to start a new thing if you
screenshot you liking the video i'll
like it from the podcast account just
tag us very cool oh [ __ ] what if they
unlike it afterwards
uh
i'll manually go back and unlike your
post if i see that
i'll come to your house does it go yeah
yo these are yo
heavy now look at this this is insane
but these aren't new subs these are just
people so these are our long-term
members yeah long-term members showing
what's up that's one of the perks of
being a member is once a month you can
send like a super chat kind of thing for
free dude that's crazy shout out to the
long time now i've never seen it go with
this one
holy crap it started 20 months ago that
was
when you could sign up so jesus yo there
are some people that have been even
older because it was actually enabled on
our um account for
a good like
year prior to us actually like
encouraging people that's true
for years there's like a very selective
there was like 20 people that were just
members i actually think our one of our
mod mega awesome nerd is like a super
long member oh is he he's longer than 20
yeah okay yeah i think so i see 20
months what's the longest we've seen 20
is the longest i've seen so far because
i think that's when we that's the man
y'all are like
these numbers are big it's all like four
five six seven eight nine ten thirteen
twenty man dude this is insane super
troopers we are coming in waves
[Applause]
damn this is crazy bro
shout outs
and thank you guys for all the love on
the behind the scenes uh it really does
mean a lot you guys encouraged me to
keep putting them out and we're happy to
do it
um there's actually someone who has beef
with you ab lorena
uh
has uh some some
something to tell you we gotta do this
i'm looking at the caption oh god go
ahead
thanks laura
hello hello
hi
hi can you hear me yeah talk to av tell
them what's your problem
um he said he really likes that some
look like a total shuttle
and then that was filmed most of it was
also right
in scotland
yeah she's saying that i was saying that
gotham was like a [ __ ] but it was
shot near her home in scotland yeah i
wasn't saying that
listen it's a movie i'm talking about
the way they portrayed it in the movie
i'm pretty sure it doesn't look like
that in real life i'm not talking about
i know the meme online of like batman
looking over the city it's not what i'm
talking about about like uh
all the thugs and everything lorena do
you buy his explanation
no i'm not really it's really
representative of what glasgow looks
like so
she doesn't buy it
man you called her neighborhood as
[ __ ] that's just
yeah she's from from glasgow she said
yeah it's from glasgow there's a pretty
um good video of the stunt rider the
riding round uh it's like a graveyard
but it's called the glasgow necropolis
they take the spell so you might enjoy
that video
well i'm sorry if i offended you i'm
sure you have a very beautiful home
that being said i've just actually moved
to connecticut because glasgow is a
[ __ ] so i live in connecticut
i was holding back but but i have heard
so many scottish people say that glasgow
is a [ __ ] well you should go to
detroit
and see which one's worse yeah baby
makes a good point yeah detroit is like
the gutter of america pretty good is the
glasgow of america yeah
my cousin tim could show you around he's
a great guy
lorena thank you so much for the call
well wow uh beautiful and welcome to
america
and good luck to you in the boxing match
i'm writing for you and i'm written for
nathan as well as his friend of mine so
written for nathan oh thank you so much
legend
shout outs
shout outs from lorena
wow we got the best fans don't we folks
well guys smash and subscribe otherwise
i'll come to your house smash
unsubscribe
you know it's a joke
i should start making like threats like
that to like prominent politicians and
stuff
it's just a joke what do you understand
drive by like a senator's house and take
pictures and videos it's a joke
hey senator i know where you live i got
all the information i need hey secret
service it's a joke
you guys think it's a joke
i don't get the i don't get the problem
he got offended how's that my fault
all right i guess this is it eh i had
too much fun today
way too much fun for one day well guys
we'll be back on wednesday you know
where we're going now
what does that mean
don't
[Music]
what weapon you guys using tell me about
your characters
i've switched to uh the moonlight katana
oh i heard that one's good you know i'm
currently doing the quest i i looked it
up i'm doing the long quest line to get
the moonlight greatsword and that's
gonna
it's gonna be my [ __ ]
you remember that from that's like a
recurrence oh the moonlight yeah of
course the moonlight crates yeah
i have the katana to start with but it's
like level 12.
the ichigatana yeah that weapon's so
good it's ridiculous yeah
it's hard to replace it it's just so
good
what are you using love
uh right now i don't really know because
i respect to be able to farm souls more
efficient efficiently then i'm gonna
respect back to my original build but
with more souls
serious business power leveling to the
max here you i notice you left out what
you respect to love oh yeah well
obviously i wouldn't play a mage
normally because that's some [ __ ] [ __ ]
thank you but i did do it for efficiency
because it's very efficient yeah
he admits that it's better it's more
efficient
dude i'm telling you i have the worst
build in the game i don't know if i can
do it i i i gotta i actually think from
a design standpoint they've in this one
made it sort of mandatory to at least
use some magic which never was a thing
in these games not me i haven't used any
magic yeah well okay mandatory is the
wrong word but like highly encouraged
like me baby well i mean that's fine but
i mean you notice that how many weapons
required every [ __ ] good weapon i get
has some faith like they purposely
wanted people yeah i agree and i'm
refusing okay well fair enough
it's like cool i was like badass boss
weapon can't use it cool ass chest
dungeon weapon can't use it i'll just
use this point i'm just going to use a
big [ __ ] club made of a tree stump
ethan you got to use that as my weapon
big red thing i got yesterday did you
see that that i sent in the group shot
oh yeah yeah yeah so it's the biggest
word in the game or the biggest mace in
the game i think actually you know what
i got
from uh
the
one of the bosses in the city capital i
don't know is he drops
a a colossal weapon that has
lightning damage
but it only requires decks and strength
so i think i found my weapon wow
it's like a dragon claw
you got that you say no i said it's like
it's made for you just for me i knew
there had to be a weapon up there you're
like we would like you to have a more
nuanced approach to this game put points
all over the board or you can use a
[ __ ] tree stump to hit things with
and i said tree stump please that is
definitely ethan's style right there
give me the tree stump
is this i'm sorry i'm lost what what is
this yeah it's uh elden elgin ring stuff
uh what i yeah i've been enjoying
playing with myself but i think we're
talking about what level are you
level five you know
that's pretty good good one dude it's
good that was good
sick whoa
100 donation don hello i've been
watching your guys since the pepsi saves
the world video you have helped me
through
so much i lost my mother this summer to
unaliven yourself wow
and your podcasts were the only thing
that helped me laugh and smile peach
peach in love
well zoe that's just horrible and tragic
i'm so sorry that that happened
peach and love to you
much peach and love
all the peaches and all the love
and i'm glad and you know i'm glad that
we're out here and able to to
make it make a make a laughs
zach you've been playing elden ring
no that's what cam said
what'd you say kim
i can't hear you you have a mic oh wait
hold on let me meet him
go cam oh check out the image i dropped
with it too
wait this is what zach's the playstation
2 one i don't get it
he picked up the wrong game
i heard all of us talking about elder
rings so much eternal ring like you got
the wrong play
looks like some highlander [ __ ] dude
looks cool yeah
the game the alden ring is kind of uh
highlander of the game you could
actually
say that it's heavily inspired by the
same uh
mythos no [ __ ] love highlander i know
you do so maybe you should get into it
i'm afraid i'm gonna have to end up
putting some stats into faith or
intelligence or something though do it
stop with them because all the fun
all the fun weapons it's just annoying i
need a strength build just put dump a
couple points into faith i'm gonna
replay the game new game plus and
respect and go all magic but the first
playthrough needs to be pure
okay
it's fair it's pure you gotta go farm
some souls dude well i need to find that
spot yeah bro i get one million souls an
hour yeah you [ __ ] the [ __ ] yeah
i had 500 000 skulls in my inventory
yesterday
it is it's that good yeah
dude you guys don't understand how silly
this how to get to it i'm literally i'm
spending my free time sitting there
farming souls in a video game
i just put on a show or a youtube video
or something and it's just funny though
like here we are on this
this
miracle of life
under the earth spiraling through space
that's right and here i am in my
basement farming souls
the vastness of space and time
it's like all i did all weekend just
farming souls what level are you i'm at
uh 75
i think i'm like level 100 i don't know
how i got that that's wild
i went to the like uh the really high
level zone
and i just started killing [ __ ] and like
there's like a big ass dragon that i
killed and there's a fort and i started
getting levels like crazy there you go
and the minor herb trees give a shitload
of he's gotta push forward oh and the
dragon on the bridge i killed him he
gave 80 000 souls
that dragon [ __ ] me up
you can you you haven't beaten him yet
no what about you love
oh i've just been forming bro
i just think you'll go back on one i'm
like you have started something very
dark inside me because i'm actually a
gaming addict and i've been ever since i
was a child and i had stopped right
after i stopped like university or
whatever it's called and i started
working and i became like an adult
um
one of our
mods rey said that uh real gamers or
sims uh just play the sims
and it's funny because this past weekend
or just yesterday specifically i was
playing eldon ring all day and i went
and checked in on ali and she was
playing the sims dude women get are
addicted to sims i don't know what it is
but women grind the sims like nothing so
here's the real kicker though is i i
in the afternoon
i come and check and she's uh she's not
actually playing the game she's on some
website downloading mods for the sim
because there's a whole universe of uh
mods for like different sets of clothes
different decorations for the house
women love everything
and i go play genders do it gender norms
do exist right women love sims
[Applause]
and i i go and play elden ring for like
four hours straight
and i go back into the office and she's
still she hasn't watched the game yet
she's still downloading mods i'm like
are you rick she's gonna [ __ ] play
she's like yeah probably not this person
kristen says she has nine thousand hours
in sims
wow
nine thousand yeah yo
i've never played sims it just doesn't
appeal to me the whole
the whole
thing i played the original when it came
out
way [ __ ] you know nineteen ninety
people
i [ __ ] around with it a little bit but
uh but i've never really got hooked on
it the way that some people do i just
wanted to woo hoo in the game
sorry woohoo it's like they're
slaying for having sex
oh
yeah they called woo hoo and you knew
that
yeah so are you secretly are you like a
big sim guy no what's what game have you
played the most in your life zach uh
batman arkham city oh that's a serious
game yeah [ __ ] love that game dude
sounds like arkham city uh yeah i think
we're living in arkham city all right
guys thank you for watching
we'll be back on wednesday
thank you thank you god bless america
and the whole world okay let's not even
limit it yeah
internationalists
[Music]
you